This is the 99% invisible breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elizabeth Chap. Today, we're covering Article 1 of the Constitution, which established the legislative branch of the federal government. And our guest for our discussion is a member of the U.S. House of Representatives, Cherise Davids. Representative Davids has served Kansas' third congressional district since 2019. She is one of the first two Native American women elected to the United States Congress,
这是《99%隐形》对美国宪法的逐条解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是伊丽莎白·查普。今天，我们要探讨的是宪法第一条，它确立了联邦政府的立法部门。我们今天的讨论嘉宾是美国众议院议员切丽丝·戴维斯。戴维斯议员自2019年起一直代表堪萨斯州第三国会选区。她是当选美国国会的最初两名美洲原住民女性之一，
along with Deb Holland from New Mexico, who was elected in the same year. She was raised by a single mother. She is a first-generation college student. She put herself through school. She eventually graduated from Cornell Law School. When people learn about her, if they can't help but mention that she was a professional, promising MMA fighter for a short period of time. I can't seem to resist it either. It's awesome.
与同年当选的新墨西哥州的德布·霍兰德并列。她由一位单亲母亲抚养长大。她是家族中第一代大学生。她靠自己的努力完成了学业。她最终毕业于康奈尔法学院。当人们了解她时，往往会忍不住提及她曾是一名很有前途的职业综合格斗（MMA）短命选手。我也似乎无法抗拒这一点。这太酷了。
If I was invited to a party with everyone in the House of Representatives, I would make a beeline to Representative David's and talk about infrastructure with her all night long. She's very into infrastructure. And it turns out she's extremely into the processes and procedures of getting things done in Congress, the hidden aspects of Article 1. That's right. And that's one of the reasons why we invited her as our book club guest. Representative Sheree Davids, thank you so much for being on the 99% invisible breakdown of the Constitution. Thank you for having me. So we're covering Article 1 of the Constitution and we're kind of dividing our discussion roughly into two parts with today's discussion centering on the first half of Article 1. So Elizabeth Cho, do you want to give us a summary of Article 1? What is it all about?
如果我受邀参加一个汇集了所有众议员的派对，我会径直走向戴维斯议员，整晚跟她聊基础设施。她对基础设施非常热衷。事实证明，她对国会办事流程和程序的执着也极深，而这些正是第一条中隐藏的方面。没错。这也是我们邀请她作为读书会嘉宾的原因之一。切丽丝·戴维斯议员，非常感谢您做客《99%隐形》宪法解析节目。谢谢你们邀请我。那么，我们要探讨的是宪法第一条，我们将把今天的讨论大致分为两部分，今天的讨论主要集中在第一条的前半部分。所以，伊丽莎白·查o，你想不想给我们总结一下第一条？它到底讲了些什么？
Sure. Here goes. Article 1 is all about Congress. The most important part is right at the beginning. And Section 1 says, all legislative powers here and granted shall be vested in a Congress of the United States, which shall consist of a Senate and House of Representatives. So basically, this first part of Article 1 gives or vests the federal government's lawmaking power to a representative body. of two houses, the House and the Senate. And the herein granted part of Section 1 means that Congress can only use power that is specifically given to it in the Constitution. So that's not like, say, the state legislatures of California or Kansas. And the first couple of sections establish the fundamentals. What are the qualifications for a member of the House? Who can be a senator? How can they be elected? Now, who sets the rules that govern Congress?
当然可以。这就来。第一条全篇都在讲国会。最重要的一部分就在开头。第一款规定：“本宪法所授之各项立法权，均属于由参议院与众议院组成之合众国国会。”所以基本上，第一条的这第一部分将联邦政府的立法权授予了一个由众议院和参议院两个院组成的代议机构。第一款中“所授之”这几个字意味着国会只能行使宪法明确授予它的权力。所以这不像，比方说加利福尼亚州或堪萨斯州的州议会。前几款确立了基本原则。众议员的资格是什么？谁可以成为参议员？他们是如何选出的？那么，谁来制定管理国会的规则呢？
does. Article 1 is also very clear about how lawmaking works. Our national bicameral legislature, that's the House and the Senate, is supposed to draft bills and then present these bills to the president for their approval or veto. Now, the big part of Congress's authority comes from Section 8, and those are the powers that Congress has. Broad but specific powers in Article 1, like the power to spend money to tax and to regulate interstate commerce. So the purpose of Article I is both to recognize the enormous power of Congress, but at the same time to reflect the concerns of the founders, that there be clear limits on what a national legislative body can do.
国会自己制定。第一条对于立法是如何运作的也写得非常清楚。我们的国家两院制立法机构，也就是众议院和参议院，应该起草法案，然后将这些法案提交给总统批准或否决。现在，国会权力的很大一部分来自于第八款，这些就是国会的权力。第一条中广泛但具体的权力，比如征税、花钱以及监管州际贸易的权力。因此，第一条的目的既是为了确认国会的巨大权力，同时也为了反映开国元勋们的担忧，即对国家立法机构能做的事情设定明确的限制。
So for most people, I think the words Article I don't have much significance in their daily lives, but it really is the how and the why of Congress. And many of the things folks might be reading about today from the massive increase in funding for ice or the freezing of federal money for cancer research or foreign aid. These are happening not just because President Trump wanted them to happen, but because of the actions or inactions of Congress itself. That's the short summary. So Representative Davis, you've been serving Kansas' third congressional district since 2019. And I'm so curious, so when you get elected, do you read and scrutinize our government? one in a different way? Because like James Madison never wrote about my job, but your employee
因此对大多数人来说，我认为“第一条”这几个字在他们的日常生活中并没有太多意义，但它确实是国会的“如何运作”以及“为何如此运作”。人们今天可能正在阅读的许多事情，从对移民及海关执法局（ICE）资金的大幅增加，到冻结用于癌症研究的联邦资金或对外援助。这些事情的发生不仅是因为特朗普总统想要它们发生，而是因为国会自身的行动或不作为。这就是简短的总结。那么，戴维斯议员，您自2019年以来一直担任堪萨斯州第三国会选区的议员。我非常好奇，当您当选后，您是否会以一种不同的方式去阅读和仔细审视我们的政府？因为就像詹姆斯·麦迪逊从未写过关于我的工作的内容，但您的员工
manual was written on stretched animal skin 250 years ago. So when you first got elected, how did the Constitution change for you? That's a great question. You know, I don't know what it's like for people who aren't lawyers when they, when they come to Congress. But the first time I really thought about the impact of the Constitution, not just Article 1, but like as a whole, document was both when I was in law school and when I was practicing law because I practiced law at the intersection of federal Indian law and corporate transactional and financing. The most common of intersections. That's right. I mean, there's at least 20 of us. No, just kidding. Now they're actually,
手册是在250年前在拉伸的动物皮上写成的。所以当您刚当选时，宪法对您来说发生了什么改变？这是一个很好的问题。你知道，我不知道那些不是律师的人在来到国会时是什么感觉。但我第一次真正思考宪法的影响，不仅是第一条，而是作为一份完整的文件，既是在我读法学院的时候，也是在我执业的时候，因为我从事的法律工作处于联邦印第安人法与公司交易和融资的交叉领域。最常见的交叉领域。没错。我的意思是，我们至少有二十个人。不，开玩笑的。现在实际上，
when I first was, when I was a baby lawyer, I think there weren't as many people practicing at that intersection, but there definitely are more now. But the reason that, I say that I had, I was already thinking a bit about that is because Congress has plenary power over the relationship between tribal governments and the federal government. And that's part of the interstate commerce clause, or sometimes what they call the Indian Commerce Clause. But when I got elected, even though I had already spent so much time thinking about Congress's powers, which powers have been vested in Congress with what was retained by the states, what carries over when it comes to tribes and federally recognized tribes and the federal government, it did
当我刚开始，当我还是个菜鸟律师时，我觉得在这个交叉领域执业的人没那么多，但现在确实更多了。但我之所以说我已经在思考这个问题，是因为国会拥有对部落政府与联邦政府之间关系的全体权力。这是州际贸易条款的一部分，有时被称为印第安贸易条款。但当我当选时，尽管我已经花了很多时间思考国会的权力——哪些权力被赋予了国会，哪些权力由各州保留，在涉及部落、联邦承认的部落以及联邦政府时有哪些延续——它确实
definitely take on a new meaning when I started this job because, well, one, just personally as a Native American in this country, who I'm Ho-Chunk from Wisconsin, which is a federally recognized tribe, it meant that my own personal relationship to my tribe and, and the kind of like my relationship to all of Indian country was different. Yeah. And so there was like a personal thing. And then there's just the impact of knowing that like, you know, for each of the members, we each represent, you know, somewhere around 700,000 people a little more in some places,
在我开始这份工作时，确实赋予了新的意义，因为，第一，仅仅作为这个国家的原住民，我是来自威斯康星州的霍昌克人，这是一个联邦承认的部落，这意味着我与我的部落之间的个人关系，以及我与整个印第安地区的关系都不同了。是的。所以有一种个人的事情。然后就是知道这样的影响，你知道，对于每一位议员来说，我们每个人都代表着，你知道，大约70万人，有些地方多一点，
a little less than others. And most people are not going to be familiar with Article 1. Most people are not going to be familiar with, like, federalism and states, you know, states' rights and the delineation of those things. And so, yeah, it, I mean, it really did take on a whole different, a whole different meaning because not only was I doing the tasks, as you said, that are laid out, you know, meeting the qualification, but then actually, like, performing the tasks of a member of Congress. I'm also, like, I'm the person who has to be most responsible in all of the Kansas third for making sure that I'm adhering to the things that are in the Constitution. I mean, that's such an interesting point because, you know, when you look at the lawmaking part of Article 1, it seems pretty straightforward, right? It's just the House and the Senate get together and they pass something and then the president decides to do something. That's right.
有些地方少一点。而且大多数人不会熟悉第一条。大多数人不会熟悉联邦制和各州，你知道，各州的权利以及这些事情的划分。所以，是的，它，我的意思是，它确实获得了一种全新的，全新的意义，因为我不仅在做你们所说的那些列出的任务，也就是满足资格条件，而且还在实际地履行国会议员的职责。我也是，我是堪萨斯州第三选区里负有最大责任的人，要确保我遵守宪法中的规定。我的意思是，这是一个非常有趣的观点，因为，你知道，当你看到第一条中关于立法的部分时，它似乎相当简单，对吧？就是众议院和参议院聚在一起通过一些法案，然后总统决定做点什么。没错。
But what I'd love to know is, you know, what's a common misconception do you think people have? Like there's probably a lot there that's not mentioned in the Constitution, right? So what is it that we should know about that's actually hard or unknown about lawmaking? I mean, one of the things, and actually I was just mentioning this to someone on my team. I was like, oh, I wonder if it's going to come up my view on, you know, when people are running for president or actually are the sitting president, often the president or presidential candidates will say something to the effect of when I when I passed this law when I wrote this law I'm going to pass a law that does X like usually you know when they're making campaign promises I'll say I'm going to pass a law
但我很想知道的是，你知道，人们有什么常见的误解？就像那里可能有很多宪法中没有提到的东西，对吧？那么，关于立法，有哪些实际上很难或者不为人知的事情是我们应该了解的？我的意思是，其中之一，其实我刚才正向我团队里的一个人提到这个。我说，哦，我不知道这会不会被谈到——我对以下事情的看法，你知道，当人们竞选总统或者实际上是现任总统时，总统或总统候选人经常会说这样的话：当我通过这个法律时，当我撰写这个法律时，我将通过一项做X事的法律——通常你知道，当他们在做出竞选承诺时，我会说我将通过一项法律
that does X and it's like I mean you'll sign it but it's actually the Congress and the Senate that passed the laws it takes effect because the president signs it and it, you know, it is their bills and then they become a law once the president signs it. But it really is like a much longer negotiation process in the House and then in the Senate. And then when the two have to come together and go into conference is what it's called when the two pass bills that are substantially similar but not exactly the same and they have to work out the differences. I just think that one, there's a lot more. steps than most people probably imagine. And then, because there's nothing in here about
来做X，这就像是，我的意思是，你会签署它，但实际上是通过法案并使其生效的是国会和参议院，因为总统签署了它，而且，你知道，这是他们的法案，一旦总统签署，它们就成了法律。但这实际上是众议院和参议院之间一个漫长得多的谈判过程。然后当两院必须走到一起并进入所谓的“会议委员会”时，也就是当两院通过了实质相似但又不完全相同的法案，并且必须解决分歧时。我只是觉得，第一，这比大多数人想象的要多出很多
committees, you know, there are committees of jurisdiction for each piece of legislation. And so there's like layers much deeper than the broad parameters that are set out by the Constitution. And the president doesn't, doesn't write the legislation, the Congress does. Yeah, yeah. So when you first start, how do you learn how to do that? What is the process? like, is there like a manual someone hands you on your first day? Not exactly, but there is, I'd say two somewhat in-depth. It's weird to say in-depth because everything moves so quickly, but we have two orientations, basically.
步骤。然后，因为这里面没有关于委员会的内容，你知道，每一项立法都有管辖委员会。因此，除了宪法规定的大框架之外，还有更深层的阶层。而且总统不，总统不编写立法，国会才编写。是的，是的。所以当你刚开始时，你是如何学习如何做这件事的？这个过程是怎样的？就像，有没有一本手册是别人在你第一天给你的？不完全是，但我想说有两个相对深入的。说“深入”很奇怪，因为一切进展都太快了，但我们基本上有两个入职培训。
There's an orientation, I guess there's three, one is optional, I guess they're all optional technically, but you know the Congressional Research Service is, it's part of the Library of Congress, and they are this like, amazing wealth of expertise. There are experts on all matters that the Congress might take up or look at. And they host an orientation for members of Congress who are just starting. I'm not sure what happens on the Senate side, but for the House, the Congressional Research Service hosts an orientation. And they go over all kinds of stuff with us. They'll go over various powers. they go over the fact that, you know, tax policy has to originate in the House.
有一个入职培训，我想有三个，一个是可选的，我想从技术上讲它们都是可选的，但你知道国会研究服务局是，它是国会图书馆的一部分，他们是一笔惊人的专业知识财富。他们是国会可能处理或研究的所有事项的专家。他们为刚开始上任的国会议员举办入职培训。我不确定参议院那边发生了什么，但对于众议院来说，国会研究服务局会举办一场入职培训。他们会和我们一起讨论各种各样的事情。他们会讨论各种权力，
They go over those types of things. And then they also help, depending on which committee assignments you are hoping to get, they'll help with, like, jurisdictional. Is this okay, how nerdy I'm getting? I feel like that's, okay. This is exactly what is the interview at this moment. Yeah, yeah. That's one of them.
他们会讨论这样一个事实，即税收政策必须在众议院发起。他们会讨论这些类型的事情。然后他们还会根据你希望加入的委员会分配，帮助你了解管辖权。我变得这么书呆子，这样可以吗？我觉得这，好吧。这正是此时此刻的采访内容。是的，是的。那是其中之一。
So the Congressional Research Service hosts something that really does help with some of the substantive policy and committee work that we might be doing. There's also a orientation that happens like in the building at the house. And some of it is, you know, it's a federal job. So some of it is like, here's your laptop. Here's your cell phone. Sign the paper. That's not in the Constitution. Yeah. No, I know. And some of it is even like, you know, we do our trainings. There's an ethics training and then, you know, like a office policy. making sure people aren't harassing each other type of training. So there's all these different things that go into making sure that we're trained up sufficiently,
因此，国会研究服务局主办的一些活动确实有助于我们开展一些实质性的政策和委员会工作。国会大厦里还会举行一场入职培训。其中一些是，你知道，这是一份联邦工作，所以有些内容类似于：这是你的笔记本电脑，这是你的手机，在这张纸上签字。宪法里可没有写这些。是的。不，我知道。其中一些甚至类似于，你知道，我们进行培训。有一个道德培训，然后，你知道，比如办公室政策，确保大家不会互相骚扰类型的培训。所以有所有这些不同的事情，以确保我们接受了充分的培训，
including like you go down to the House floor and they're like, this is your voting card. Here's how you use the machine. But I will say, just so you guys know, when someone comes in in a special election, they don't get any of that. Oh. So they just fly by the same. Yeah. I mean, it's like an on-the-job training. for at least a portion of it, because usually when a special election happens, the person gets sworn in, like, a lot of times, like, literally in the middle of a vote series.
包括你走到众议院大厅，他们会说，这是你的投票卡，这是你如何使用机器。但我得说，为了让你们知道，当有人通过特别选举进入国会时，他们什么都没有。哦。所以他们只是凭经验摸索。是的。我的意思是，这就像是在职培训，至少有一部分是这样，因为通常当特别选举发生时，这个人宣誓就职的时间，很多时候，简直就是在投票进行到一半的时候。
So it'll be like, we have a procedural vote, and then the person gets sworn in, and then debate starts on a piece of legislation, and then later that day they'll have to come in and vote. Do you see them just wandering around aimlessly on the House floor and just try to help them out? I mean, you know, Congress is filled with just like humans. So a lot of times what happens is it's like a new kid being at school. So like someone comes in and everybody's all like, oh, congratulations. And actually people are coming up just so you guys know from both sides of the aisle to congratulate someone when they've come in in a special election. And it's just a lot more like volume and chaos at the very beginning of a session of Congress. So when we're all coming in for the first time, or it's the new session, we're all going around and congratulating all of our new colleagues and stuff.
所以它会像这样：我们有一场程序性投票，然后这个人宣誓就职，然后开始就一项立法进行辩论，当天晚些时候他们就必须进来投票。你看到他们在众议院大厅里漫无目的地闲逛并试图帮助他们吗？我的意思是，你知道，国会里到处都只是普通人。所以很多时候发生的情况就像一个新孩子去上学。所以有人进来，大家都在说，哦，恭喜恭喜。事实上，为了让你们知道，两党的人都会走过来，向通过特别选举进入国会的人表示祝贺。在一届国会刚开始时，会有更多的音量和混乱。所以当我们所有人第一次来，或者迎来新一届国会时，我们都在四处走动，祝贺我们所有的、新同事之类的。
It doesn't mean we're not going to, like, argue and fight about stuff later, but... So you mentioned the formal steps about how to get acclimated as a member of the house, but what about that sort of informal stuff? How does one figure that out when you're newly elected? Like, who is the person to talk to and you need to, you know, get your voice heard in a committee? How does that work? Yeah. I can tell you how I did it. a lot of it was really looking around and seeing who are the more senior members that are doing
这并不意味着我们以后不会为事情争吵和打架，但……所以你提到了关于如何作为一名众议院议员适应环境的正式步骤，但那些非正式的事情呢？当你刚刚当选时，如何才能弄清楚这些？比如，当你需要让自己的声音在委员会中被听到时，应该和谁谈谈？这究竟是如何运作的？是的。我可以告诉你我是怎么做的。很多时候真的是环顾四周，看看谁是那些正在做我感兴趣的事情的资深议员。
the things that I'm interested in. And so I can tell you when I first came to Congress, Nancy Pelosi was elevated to speaker in my first term, reelected as speaker, I should say. And then Steny Hoyer was our majority leader. And so he was the person who ran the floor. So the majority leader is the person who's in charge of the house floor, which means they set the calendar. So, you know, if you can go to Congress.gov and see what is the legislative calendar for 20205. And then at the beginning of 2026, the majority leader, and that's true for either side of the aisle, the majority leader will set the calendar for the whole calendar year. They also determine and negotiate with the majority and the minority side. negotiate these things, which bill, like how many bills, and this is done in ratios, like how many
所以我可以告诉你，当我第一次来到国会时，南希·佩洛西在我第一个任期内被提升为议长，应该说是再次当选为议长。然后斯坦尼·霍耶是我们的多数党领袖。所以他负责掌控会场。因此，多数党领袖是负责众议院会场的人，这意味着他们负责制定日程表。所以，你知道，你可以访问Congress.gov，看看20205年的立法日程是什么。然后在2026年初，多数党领袖——两党都是如此——多数党领袖将为整个日历年制定日程。他们还决定并与多数党和少数党进行谈判。就这些事情进行谈判，哪个法案，比如多少
bills are going to be put on the suspension calendar, which means that they don't go through the regular rules committee process, then there are bills that are subject to a rule, and we vote and pass what are the parameters of that rule. The majority leader is, the office is in charge of all of that. Like, that's their, that's within their, that's within their her view. And so I asked Steny Hoyer and his team, his floor staff, and there's a floor director, I asked them all kinds of questions. Like, you know, what is a discharge petition? How many people need to sign it? How do we decide if something is on suspension or subject to a rule? And usually whoever's the majority leader and the staff in that office are kind of the
法案将被列入暂停审议日程表（suspension calendar），这意味着它们不经过常规的规则委员会程序，然后还有一些受规则约束的法案，我们投票并通过该规则的参数。多数党领袖的办公室负责所有这些。这属于他或她的职责范围。因此，我向斯坦尼·霍耶和他的团队、他的会场工作人员——那里有一位会场主任——提出了各种各样的问题。比如，你知道，什么是解除请愿书？需要多少人签名？我们如何决定某事是暂停审议还是受规则约束？通常，无论是谁担任多数党领袖以及该办公室的工作人员，都算是会场规则方面的专家。
experts on literally like the rules of the floor. And so, you know, there's there's the big picture constitution. We originate tax legislation. And then there's the, okay, but what month are we going to handle that? How many, like how many, how many, how many bills related to tax are we going to do? When are they going to actually come to the floor? And how long is it going to take to get through the Ways and Means Committee, then the Rules Committee, and then come to the floor. So I literally thought that seems really interesting. So I went and asked the people that I could tell were working on that. And then I did a lot of asking, like, hey, I'm interested in, like, on transportation and infrastructure, I'm on, I'm going to try to dig into the most nerdy thing,
所以，你知道，有宏观层面的宪法。我们发起税收立法。然后还有，好吧，但是我们在哪个月处理这件事？多少，比如多少，多少，多少与税收相关的法案我们要处理？它们什么时候真正提交到会场？通过筹款委员会、规则委员会，然后提交到会场需要多长时间？所以我literally觉得这听起来真的很有趣。所以我去问了那些我能看出在做这方面工作的人。然后我做了很多询问，比如，嘿，我对交通和基础设施感兴趣，我在，我要试着深入探讨最书呆子的事情，如果可以的话。是的，绝对可以。请讲。交通和基础设施委员会
if that's okay. Yeah, absolutely. Please. Transportation and Infrastructure. has jurisdiction over the federal, over federal buildings. Federal buildings actually make up quite a bit of, if you look at emissions, carbon emissions, all buildings, any kind of building, generally is responsible. That's like a pretty decent size percentage of carbon emissions in our country. The federal government has a ton of inventory of federal buildings that, that we own. And the building codes for federal buildings would any kind of building codes for federally owned buildings would come under the jurisdiction of the Transportation and Infrastructure Committee because we have a subcommittee that's that addresses that emergency management,
对联邦建筑拥有管辖权。如果你看看排放量、碳排放量，联邦建筑实际上占了相当大的比重，任何类型的建筑，一般来说都是负责任的。这大约是我们国家碳排放中一个相当体面的百分比。联邦政府拥有大量我们自己拥有的联邦建筑库存。任何联邦所有的建筑的建筑规范都将属于交通和基础设施委员会的管辖范围，因为我们有一个专门处理该问题的分委员会：应急管理、
the economic development agency, which is in the Department of Commerce. So there's like this hodgepodge of things in there. And I was very interested in that. So I was like, who, once I found out that T&I, because I sit on that committee, has jurisdiction over that. I was like, oh, well, who do I talk to? And so we had a couple of experts come in. I often reach out to the Congressional Research Service to come and do briefings to help me and the people on my team understand how did we get to the policy place we're at right now. And what are some of the proposals that have come up that either never got voted on or, because we might be able to find that sort of thing out, or did get voted on and just didn't get adopted. So there's a bunch of
经济发展局，它隶属于商务部。所以里面有各种各样的大杂烩。我对那个非常感兴趣。所以我想，一旦我发现交通和基础设施委员会——因为我坐在这个委员会里——对那拥有管辖权，我就想，哦，好吧，我该跟谁谈谈呢？所以我们请来了几位专家。我经常联系国会研究服务局，让他们来进行简报，帮助我和我团队里的人了解我们是如何到达目前所在的政策立场的。以及有哪些曾经从未被投票表决过的提案，或者因为我们也许能查到那种事情，或者被投票表决过但只是没有被采纳的提案。所以有很多
different avenues. You can ask the committee staff, and usually committee staff are there for, they kind of have a longer tenure of service on the hill. And they're usually like substantive experts. You can ask other members who've been there for a little while. You can ask, hopefully your own team will be able to help you figure some of that stuff out. You can ask the experts at home. So for transportation and infrastructure, the Kansas City metro area, like we have the second largest rail hub in the country, the Kansas and Missouri meet here, we have a number of major highways that intersect here. So there's just, there's a lot of expertise at home in each member's district. Did that answer the question? I'm sorry.
不同的途径。你可以询问委员会的工作人员，通常委员会工作人员在那里，他们在国会山有更长的任职期限。他们通常是实质性专家。你可以问问其他在那里呆了一段时间的议员。你可以问，希望你自己的团队能够帮你弄清楚其中一些事情。你可以问家里的专家。所以对于交通和基础设施来说，堪萨斯城大都会区，比如我们拥有全国第二大的铁路枢纽，堪萨斯州和密苏里州在这里交汇，多条主要高速公路在这里交错。因此，在每位议员的选区里，家里都有大量的专业知识。这回答了那个问题吗？对不起。
Yeah, I think you asked how do we get, how do I, how do I get up to speed on that stuff? I mean, it absolutely does, but it points to another part of the Constitution that I actually want to highlight, which is like in Article 1, Section 5, there's this phrase that says, each house may determine the rules of its proceedings, which is a very short, you know, like, section of a sentence of which so much of what you just said is like embedded in that those few words that these proceedings are extremely complicated. They can be dry to some. I find them kind of invigorating. It sounds like you kind of find them invigorating, you know. Can you sort of explain why these procedures, why these things are set up in this way? Do you feel the import of them when you're when you're sort of navigating these different committees and things and jurisdictions? Like their role is important. Yeah. I mean, I do. And I feel like most members of Congress do. Even if I don't, I mean, we might not agree on a bunch of stuff. But when I'm interacting with my colleagues, I often do feel like the magnitude of.
是的，我想你问的是我们如何跟上这些事情的进度？我的意思是，这绝对回答了，但它指向了宪法中我实际上想要强调的另一部分，也就是在第一条第五款中，有这样一句话：“各院得自行确定其议事规则”，这是一个非常短的、你知道的、句子的一部分，你刚才所说的大部分内容都嵌入在那几个字里，即这些议事程序极其复杂。对某些人来说可能很枯燥。我发现它们有点让人振奋。听起来你也有点觉得它们振奋人心，你知道。你能解释一下为什么这些程序、为什么这些事情会以这种方式设立吗？当你在这个不同的委员会和管辖范围中穿梭时，你是否能感受到它们的重要性？就像它们的作用很重要。是的。我的意思是，我确实有这种感觉。我觉得大多数国会议员也都有。即使我没有，我的意思是，我们可能在很多事情上意见不一。但当我与我的同事互动时，我经常觉得
what we're doing is pretty like apparent. But I also, I mean, this is one of those things that I try to keep in mind. If I ever think that what I'm doing feels like something that's just kind of like perfunctory or whatever, then I, that's probably time to start looking at other stuff because, like something else to do because literally like every, like, every, single thing the Congress does is important. And there are some things that are less contentious, but doesn't make them less important. There are some things that are less hot button, but they're not less important. You know, I mentioned the suspension calendar, and sometimes people will say, oh, those are just suspension bills. Other people who know
我们正在做的事情的分量是相当显而易见的。但我也，我的意思是，这是我尽量记住的事情之一。如果我曾经觉得我正在做的事情感觉就像是某种例行公事之类的，那么，这可能就是开始寻找其他事情的时候了——就像寻找其他可以做的事情一样，因为字面上，像每一项，国会所做的每一件事都很重要。有些事情争议较小，但这并不意味着它们不重要。有些事情不那么引人注目，但它们并不不重要。我提到了暂停审议日程表，有时人们会说，“哦，那些只是暂停法案。”而其他了解国会山运作方式和立法进程的人会知道，暂停法案将会通过。你知道，我们会获得超过三分之二的赞成。它需要三分之二的议员投票赞成。如果它在暂停审议日程表上，那是因为它没有争议，并且许多事情已经解决。而且通常，很多时候它就像是在解决我们在项目中看到的问题。但这并不意味着它不重要。
how the Hill works and how the legislative process works, like a suspension bill, is going to pass. You know, we're going to get more than two-thirds. It requires two-thirds of the members to vote in favor of it. If it's on a suspension calendar, it's because it's non-controversial and a bunch of the things have been worked out. And it's usually, a lot of times it's like addressing issues that we see in programs. But that doesn't mean it's not important. Like, they're all important. Every single vote that a member of Congress takes is important, whether it's a procedural vote to like we have to we basically vote on a procedural matter to just even be able to vote on the floor for a bill you know so we're like voting on whether or not we're
它们都很重要。国会议员投下的每一张票都很重要，无论是程序性投票——比如我们必须对程序性事项进行投票，甚至才能在会场上对一项法案进行投票，你知道，所以我们是在投票决定我们是否要投票——但它，而且它可能会显得，你知道，对于一个不花时间、也不应该花时间去思考国会做的每一件小事的人来说……但对于我们这些正在做这件事的人来说，每当我把我的卡片插进读卡器投票时，我都是代表着超过70万人在这样做，你知道吗？所以无论我投赞成票还是反对票，即使这是一场程序性投票，它也很重要，因为这字面意思是人民的声音在华盛顿特区被听到或没有被听到。因此，我认为很多人认识到了它的重要性，比如大楼里的许多人，国会大厦里的许多人。但这也听起来你所说的是，在众议院成事的关键在于成为一个程序书呆子，如果不深入了解程序，你就无法成事。是这样吗？是的。我的意思是，而且我认为关于国会有趣的一件事情是，目标并不总是去真正地
going to vote but and it and it might seem you know to someone who doesn't spend nor should they like doesn't spend their time thinking about every single little thing that congress does But for those of us who are doing it, like every time I put my card in the reader to vote, I'm doing that on behalf of like over 700,000 people, you know? So whether I vote yes or no, even if it's a procedural vote, it matters because that's literally the people's voice being heard or not in D.C. And so I think that a lot of people recognize the importance, like a lot of the people who are in the building, who are in the capital. But it also sounds like what you're saying is that the key to getting things done in the house is being a procedure nerd that you can't get things done without knowing procedures intimately. Is that right? Yeah. I mean, and I think the interesting thing I think about the Congress is the goal isn't always to actually. get a piece of legislation done in that term, even though, like, ultimately, that probably
在那个任期内完成一项立法，尽管，最终，那可能确实是目标。但是，而且我，我没有做很多这方面的事，但你会，你可以，你通常可以分辨出一件事情什么时候是为了发信号（messaging），什么时候是为了成为一项实质性立法。我这么说并不是因为——而且这不是一个政治政党的事情。这字面意思是，有时你可能可以回顾任何一项重大立法，建立小企业管理局。我想我们已经成立大约52年了吧。这之所以浮现在脑海是因为我得以去参加一个庆祝活动，因为德怀特·艾森豪威尔，艾森豪威尔总统是签署那项立法的人。我敢打赌，我们可以回顾国会历史，看到
is the goal. But, and I don't, I don't do a lot of this, but you'll, you can, you can often tell when something is meant for messaging and when something is, is meant to be a piece of, of substantive legislation. And I say that not because, and this is not a, that's not a political part. party thing. That's literally like sometimes you could probably go back and look at any major piece of legislation, getting the small business administration set up. I think we're at like 52 years or something that that's been set up. And it comes to mind because I got to go to a celebration because Dwight Eisenhower, President Eisenhower is the one who signed that piece of legislation. And I bet we could go back into the congressional history and see
多项被引入并，你知道的，在众议院通过或在参议院通过的立法，它们没有通过会议委员会，就像最初引入的那样，只存在于当时有管辖权的任何委员会中。你可以翻看并看到像建立一个部委或机构这样重大事情的演变和过程。我相信当美国农业部成立或内政部成立时，也发生了同样的事情。你知道，印第安人事务局，过去实际上设在战争部内。然后当内政部成立时，他们搬迁了，他们把印第安人事务局或BIA搬到了内政部内，这对美国来说是一个重大的政策转变。因此，肯定有一些立法被引入，我敢肯定。我不能说，我还没有研究过是哪些法案。但我敢肯定，有立法被引入，试图弄清楚既然政策转变一直在发生，国会将如何改变联邦政府与联邦承认的部落之间的实际互动。政治转变变成了政策转变，再变成了立法转变。这说得通吗？说得通。
multiple pieces of legislation that were introduced and, you know, passed in the House or passed in the Senate, they didn't make it through conference, like was initially introduced and only was in whichever committee at the time had jurisdiction. And you can go through and you can see the evolution and process of something major like a department or an agency getting set up. I'm sure the same thing happened when the USDA came into being or the Department of Interior. you know, the, for the Bureau of Indian Affairs, that used to actually be situated in the Department of War. And then when the Department of Interior was created, they moved over, they moved the Bureau of Indian Affairs or the BIA over into the Department of Interior, which was a major policy shift for the United States. So there were pieces of legislation that were getting introduced, I'm sure of it. I can't say, I haven't done the research on which pieces. But I'm sure there were pieces of legislation getting introduced to try to figure out how is Congress going to change the actual interaction between the federal government and federally recognized tribes now that the policy shift has been happening. There was a political shift that turned into a policy shift that turned into a legislative shift. Does that make sense? It does.
是的，绝对如此。太迷人了。但这指出了第一条中的一件事，那就是任期限制。众议员被限制在仅仅两年，这限制了你能完成多少工作。这意味着当你考虑立法时，你可能得把它看作是一件会发生在这个任期之后的事情，因为众议院议员本来就是要通过更频繁的选举来承担问责制的。而参议院不知何故，你知道，它与此略有不同，被置于较少受问责的地位。而且过去也不是直接选举产生的。好吧，当然。
Yeah, absolutely. So fascinating. But it points to one of the things that is in Article 1, which is the term limits. House members are limited to just two years, which limits how much you can get done. It means that when you're thinking about legislation, you might have to think about it as something that's going to happen past this term because the House representatives were supposed to be subject to accountability with more frequent elections. And the Senate was somehow, you know, it was slightly different from that held off to be to be less accountable. And also didn't used to be directly elected. Well, of course.
没错。这是一个有趣的。这绝对是一个有趣的改变。我能分享一些关于这方面的事情吗？请讲。当然。关于众议院。所以我的确认为这是我直到进入国会才会有所思考的事情，那就是国会，就像，你必须通过选举产生。
That's right. Which is an interesting. It totally is an interesting change. Can I share something about that? Please. Sure. About the House. So I do think this is something that I never would have thought about until I got to Congress, which is that Congress, like, you have to be elected.
在参议院，你可以被任命，如果出现空缺，比如州长或委员会之类的人可以任命。在众议院，没有人可以被任命为众议院议员。而我们是最接近人民的这个概念，你知道，我们有，因为有很多选区，但在我们每个选区中，我们在选民和人口方面的数量是最少的。因为然后，你知道，对于参议院来说，他们每个州有两名，我想这让怀俄明州和不管怎样。是的，所以我想有些参议院议员代表的人比众议院议员还要少。但关键是，你。
In the Senate, you can be appointed, like a governor or a commission or something can, if there's a vacancy. In the House, no one can ever be appointed to the House of Representatives. And this concept of us being the closest to the people, you know, we have, because there are so many districts, but we have the smallest number in terms of, of constituency and population in each of our districts. Because then, you know, with the Senate, they have two for, I guess that makes like Wyoming and anyway. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. So I guess there's some senators who represent less people than House members. But point being that you, you. Like, when we say, like, the people's house, that is actually a thing that I, that, that, that, that my colleagues really feel. Um, and I can, I can tell in conversation with people and it gets brought up a lot. And it's something that until, until I got there, I, I don't even know if I ever would have noticed somebody saying the people's house. I wouldn't have probably, I don't know if I would have thought about it in the way that when members of Congress are saying that what they actually mean,
就像，当我们说，像“人民众议院”时，那实际上是一件真实存在的事情，我的同事们确实有这种感觉。嗯，而且我可以，我从与人们的谈话中能感觉到，而且这经常被提起。这是我在去到那里之前，甚至不知道我是否会注意到有人说“人民的众议院”。我可能不会，我不知道我是否会以国会议员在说这话时他们实际意思的那种方式去思考它，
which is like, we are the federal electives who are the closest to the people. And you cannot get into the House of Representatives without going through an election. And there is some, I do think there is something special about that, both because it means that there was enough people who were, like, trusted you enough to be willing to checkmark your name on the box. But also that it means that the accountability, you know, a senator can be, and I'm not, this is not to disparage senators at all, but it's like, you know, you can get into the, you can be a United States senator without ever having gone through an election, which means that, like, you can get into the Senate and be making laws without ever having had the majority of the people that you're representing, checkmark your name and say, I trust this person to make decisions on my behalf. And, and I do think, that's like so to the to the point about the accountability and the every two years I do think
也就是：我们是离人民最近的联邦民选官员。你不可能不经过选举就进入众议院。而且我认为这其中有一些特殊的东西，不仅因为它意味着有足够多的人，就像，足够信任你，愿意在方框里给你的名字打勾。而且这也意味着问责制，你知道，参议员可以——我不是，这绝不是贬低参议员——但就像，你知道，你可以进入参议院，成为一名美国参议员，而无需经历过一场选举，这意味着，就像，你可以进入参议院并制定法律，而从未有过你所代表的大多数人在你的名字上打勾并说“我相信这个人会代表我做出决定”。而且，我确实认为，这就说到关于问责制和每两年一次的要点，我确实认为
there's there's a level of importance and like investment that a bunch of house members really have in that well that having been said I would imagine that the moment you enter the house for your term you start thinking from day one about re-election right and so you know all of this being true being representing the people you know do you think in 2025 if we could rewrite article one from scratch. Would you want the length of a House member's term to be maybe just a bit longer? Yeah. I mean, I have spent like some time kind of like, you know, turning that over in my head. I have felt since I started this job particularly that the structure that we have is actually like pretty good. I mean, you know, there's a, there's no one right way to do.
许多众议院议员对此有着一定程度的重要性和投入，好吧，话虽如此，我想象当你踏入众议院开始任期那一刻起，你就会从第一天开始考虑连任，对吧？所以，你知道，这一切都是真的，代表着人民，你知道，你认为在2025年，如果我们能从头重写第一条。你是否会希望众议院议员的任期稍微长一点点？是的。我的意思是，我确实花了一些时间，有点像，你知道，在脑子里琢磨过这件事。自从我开始这份工作以来，我特别觉得我们拥有的结构实际上“相当不错”。我的意思是，你知道，没有一种唯一正确的方法来做
do anything. If there was, we wouldn't even need to do all of this. But the thing is, there's not a right way. There's like some ways that are better than others. And I think that having the mixture of representation by population, representation by state, so the House is represented by population, the Senate is represented by state. We've got an executive whose job is to execute on the laws, but they have to be elected by, I know we've got the Electoral College, but they have to be elected by the entire country. That has a system, there's a system there of different levels of accountability. I think the two-year term and the six-year term, like I can see why that was, why that was put into the Constitution because, you know, it was it was a pushback against
任何事情。如果有的话，我们甚至不需要做所有这些。但问题是，没有唯一正确的方法。有些方法比其他方法更好。我认为拥有按人口代表和按州代表的混合体——因此众议院按人口代表，参议院按州代表。我们有一个行政部门，其工作是执行法律，但他们必须由——我知道我们有选举人团——但他们必须由整个国家选举产生。那有一个系统，那里存在着不同问责级别的系统。我认为两年任期和六年任期，就像我能理解为什么，为什么会被写入宪法，因为，你知道，这是对
a monarchy, a tyrannical monarchy. And it's like, okay, so two years probably made sense when they were only, you know, I mean, when they were counting like 16 million people, when there were like 30 million people in the country and a certain number of states. But as the country has grown, I don't know. know if in this moment we would do a two-year term because the cycle feels so, because it, what that, the consequence is that it almost feels like there's no, there's no end or beginning. It's literally just a cycle, an endless cycle of, of politics and politicking and that sort of thing. I can say that for, from the legislative perspective, I do think about now, I mean, I'm in my fourth term. now. So I do think about if there's something that, if there are changes that we're trying to make that might be more substantive when you think about, and I'm, because I'm on transportation and infrastructure and it's really like my area of passion, you know, like major
君主制、暴君式君主制的反击。而且就像，好吧，当他们只有，你知道，我的意思是，当他们统计大约1600万人口，当国家有大约3000万人口和一定数量的州时，两年可能是有意义的。但随着国家的成长，我不知道。在这个时刻，我们是否会实行两年任期，因为周期感觉太……因为，其结果是，它几乎感觉没有终点或起点。它字面意思只是一个循环，政治和政客把戏等等的无休止的循环。我可以从立法的角度说，我现在在想，我的意思是，我现在在我的第四个任期了。所以我的确在考虑，如果有什么事情，如果我们试图做出一些在考虑时可能更实质性的改变，而且我是因为我在交通和基础设施委员会，这真的就像我的热情所在，你知道，就像重大
infrastructure projects are usually, those are on like a 10-year time frame. Absolutely. You know? Right. And so there's something really different. disjointed and ineffective about having people making decisions on two-year timeframes for projects that take 10 years to come to fruition. And so I think about ways that we can alleviate some of that disjointedness. And some of it is like increasing pace of being able to get projects done. So permitting reform would probably be like the most, salient example right now. We've been talking about permitting reforms since I got to, maybe since my second term. And I say we, meaning me personally, me and my team,
基础设施项目通常都是以10年为周期的。完全同意。你知道的吗？是的。所以，让那些在两年周期内为需要10年才能见效的项目做决定的人来做决策，这种做法非常与实际脱节，而且低效。因此我在思考如何能缓解这种脱节现象。其中一部分就是提高完成项目的速度。所以，审批改革可能是目前最显著的例子。自从我来到国会，或者说从我的第二任期开始，我们就一直在讨论审批改革。这里说的“我”，是指我个人、我和我的团队，
like engaging in like substantive conversations about how do we, how do we do permitting reform? We need to, some of the regulatory and legislative, you know, I'm putting this in air quote, burdens or barriers exist because we don't want a lake catching on fire, you know, like clean water, clean air. Those things exist for a reason. But there are so much of our climate and environmental policy is, is so old that like we have technologies that are, that have completely alleviated some of the concerns that would have existed before and slowed down a process. But, you know, you've got the federal government with their policies. You've got the state level government. And in some cases, you have local stuff. And that's just on the
一直在进行实质性的对话，讨论我们该如何推进审批改革。我们需要……你知道的，我这里用空气引号，之所以存在一些监管和立法上的“负担”或“障碍”，是因为我们不希望湖泊着火，你知道的，比如清洁的水、清洁的空气。这些东西的存在是有原因的。但是，我们的许多气候和环境政策都太陈旧了，以至于我们现在拥有的一些技术已经完全缓解了过去可能存在并拖慢进程的一些顾虑。但是，你知道的，联邦政府有他们的政策，州级政府也有，在某些情况下，还有地方政策。而这仅仅是关于
environmental piece of permitting reform. Then there's, there's all the different touch points of getting a project done. And because of that, I mean, it's complex, you know. And if you think you're going to introduce a piece of legislation, get it through a committee, which, like, something with permitting reform would touch on like multiple committees, the Energy and Commerce Committee, Transportation and Infrastructure, probably some other one like USDA might be impact. There's all these different committees that come in to play. And then you have the whole house floor, so 435 members.
审批改革中的环保部分。此外，完成一个项目还有许多不同的接触点。正因如此，我的意思是，这很复杂，你知道的。如果你认为你要提出一项立法草案，让它通过委员会——而审批改革这样的事情会触及多个委员会，比如能源和商务委员会、交通和基础设施委员会，可能还有其他委员会比如美国农业部也会受到影响。有这么多不同的委员会参与其中。然后是整个众议院全会，也就是435名成员。
So if you think in two years, you're going to be able to get. like, for the first time, introduce a piece of legislation, get it through the committees, get it through the floor, just in the House, get it, like, have the Senate take it up, go through their process with committees and getting it to the floor, and then go to conference and get all of that done in two years. It's just, like, that's just not going to happen. But what you can do is introduce legislation, get to work on it, have it in the committee. People, you know, the negotiation process starts.
所以，如果你认为在两年内你能做到——比如第一次提出一项立法，让它通过委员会，让它通过全会，仅仅在众议院完成，然后让参议院接手，经历他们的委员会流程并送交全会，然后通过两院协商会议，在两年内完成这一切。这简直……这根本不可能发生。但你能做的是提出立法，开始着手处理，把它放在委员会里。人们，你知道的，谈判过程就开始了。
maybe it makes it through committee the first time around or the second time around. So when I think about like major policy changes, I think about how many terms do we think this would take in the House. The Senate, luckily, because there's there for six years, like, you know, that's three terms. So probably you can really build up some momentum with certain senators and you can build up momentum with House members who are likely to be around for, you know, longer than, longer than one or two terms. So you're saying Article 1 is not designed for efficiency? No, but I actually don't know if it should be. I mean, this doesn't mean make things inefficient when it comes to federal programs and stuff.
也许它在第一次或第二次审议时就能通过委员会。所以，当我想象重大的政策变革时，我会想我们认为这在众议院需要花费几个任期。参议院幸运的是，因为他们任期是六年，你知道的，那是三个期。所以你可能会与某些参议员建立起一些势头，并且你可以与那些可能会任职（你知道的）比一两个任期更长的众议院成员建立起势头。所以你是说第一条并不是为了效率而设计的？不，但我其实不知道它是否应该如此。我的意思是，这并不意味着在涉及联邦项目之类的事情时让事情变得低效。
If the federal government's doing it, it should be done well and it should be done efficiently. But if we're going to make changes that impact literally every single person in this kind of, country. I'm not sure if it should, I'm not sure if it's something that should sail through super quickly. Should it take 10 years? Probably not. So it's not built for efficiency, but I'm not sure inefficiency is, um, is caused by the constraints of the constitution so much as the like messiness of, of human negotiation. Yeah. You know, there are a lot of powers listed in the later sections. But it's interesting to me that the power to impeach is like right there, like front and center. Like it says like here's the House
如果联邦政府在做这件事，那就应该做好，而且应该高效地完成。但如果我们要做出的改变会影响到这个国家的每一个普通人。我不确定它是否应该，我不确定它是否应该是那种能够轻舟过重山般迅速通过的事。应该花10年时间吗？可能不应该。所以它不是为效率而建的，但我不确定低效是因为宪法的限制造成的，还是因为人类谈判的混乱造成的。是的。你知道的，后文列出了许多权力。但令我感兴趣的是，弹劾权就像那样，直接摆在最显眼、最核心的位置。它就像是说，众议院在这里
Representatives. What they do is impeach. You know, like it's like listed in the first section of their introduction. And it makes me think of like this is really there, a lot of the concern when they're writing this is the balance of powers. Yeah, the checks and balances. Do you read it that way, first of all? And like, what do you think about the balance of powers in the current moment? how it's evolved over time. It's so interesting because while the power to impeach is, I mean, it's right there. There's not that many things that are like directly laid out. It's like impeachment and post offices, you know, or like impeachment war, post offices and taxes. The list of specifics that are laid out in the Constitution, it's a pretty short list. But in some ways, it speaks.
代表。他们要做的事就是弹劾。你知道的，就像它被列在他们介绍的第一节里一样。这让我想起，这确实存在，当他们撰写这些内容时，很大一部分担忧是关于权力分立的。是的，就是制衡。首先，你是这样解读它的吗？还有，你如何看待当前时刻的权力分立？以及它是如何随时间演变的。这太有趣了，因为虽然弹劾权——我的意思是，它就在那里。没有多少事情是被直接详细规定的。就像弹劾和邮局一样，你知道的，或者像弹劾、战争、邮局和税收。宪法中列出的具体事项清单其实相当短。但在某些方面，它说明了
to the import. Like, how important is it that impeachment is laid out? To me, it means that it's probably something that should be done very rarely and in the most egregious and, like, significant times. And then it's the responsibility of the Senate to truly, like, dig in and investigate and essentially perform the function of the, you know, the trial for an impeachment. I think that because of the current climate, it's the type of thing that it gets brought up like this, you know, like it gets brought up so quickly. And whether it's the president or Supreme Court justices or other, you know, officers that can be impeached, just because something can be done doesn't mean that that is the, that that's the most effective way to address an issue that is happening. And I I do think that the fact that it's even mentioned in the Constitution to me means that it's of such great importance that it shouldn't be just thrown around really lightly, if that makes sense. But maybe it would be nice if there was a little more of a direct correlation for the benefit of others that Congress sets the rules and parameters and process for everything that we do. because impeachment is also, it's a whole process. It's not, it's not like one vote, which maybe is one of the misconceptions. I should have, that's right. I should have mentioned earlier. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's an interesting part of it. Yeah. And it's really weird to, like, the number of things that I've happened in the Congress that I've been a part of since I got here is, is pretty wild. Just, you know, I've participated in two, um, two.
重要性。弹劾被详细列出到底有多重要？对我来说，这意味着这可能是一项应该极少使用的事情，并且应该在最恶劣、最重大的时候使用。然后参议院有责任真正地深入调查，并实质上履行弹劾审判的职能。我认为由于当前的政治气候，这种事就变成了那种会被频繁提出的话题，你知道的，就是被提出得太快了。无论是针对总统、最高法院大法官还是其他可以被弹劾的官员，仅仅因为某件事可以被做到，并不意味着那是解决正在发生的问题的最有效方法。而且我确实认为，它甚至在宪法中被提及这一事实，对我来说意味着它是如此重要，以至于不应该被轻率地抛出来，如果这样说能理解的话。但也许如果能为其他人带来多一点的直接关联性会更好，即国会为我们所做的一切制定规则、参数和程序。因为弹劾也是一个完整的流程。它不是，它不是像一次投票那么简单，这可能是一个误解。我本应该——没错。我本应该早点提出来的。是的。是的。是的。这是其中有趣的部分。Yeah。而且真的挺奇怪的，自打我来到这里以来，在我经历的国会里发生的事情的数量，相当疯狂。你知道的，我参与了两个，嗯，两个
impeachments that like went through the full process, the process and procedure of an impeachment. Yeah. I mean, does it feel heavy when you're going through it? Yeah. One, there's an oath. Like, you take an oath when you get sworn into office to protect and defend the Constitution and the United States against all enemies foreign and domestic. And so, you know, there's a level of importance around that. I grew up in Army Brat. It was just me and my mom. And then I have two little brothers or eight and nine years younger than me. So for like a lot of my formative years, it was just me and my mom. And the president is also the commander in chief of the military. Like I don't think that impeachment is something that this is like a tool of last resort in my opinion, you know, because, you know, democracy doesn't mean that you agree with the outcome of all the elections. Yeah, in fact, it almost means the opposite. Yeah, I mean, you know, I don't remember, I think, I think at one of the state, like, I get to go to the state of the union.
经历过完整流程的弹劾案，也就是弹劾的流程和程序。是的。我的意思是，当你经历它的时候，会感到沉重吗？是的。第一，有宣誓。比如，当你宣誓就职时，你发誓要保护和捍卫宪法以及美利坚合众国，抵御一切国内外的敌人。所以，你知道的，这周围有一种重要性。我在军队家庭（Army Brat）长大。家里只有我和我妈妈。然后我有两个小弟弟，比我小八九岁。所以在我的很多成长岁月中，家里只有我和我妈妈。而总统同时也是军队的最高统帅。我不认为弹劾是某种——在我看来，这是一种最后的手段，因为（你知道的），民主并不意味着你同意所有选举的结果。是的，事实上，它几乎意味着相反的东西。是的，我的意思是，你知道的，我不记得了，我想，我想在某个国情咨文中，我有机会去参加国情咨文。
Like, that's crazy. Like, cool, you know. But one of the things that I'm pretty sure President Biden said during one of the state of the union addresses that I went to was that you, don't get to love our country just when the person you wanted to win wins. Like, we got to, you know, we got to have respect and love for our country, regardless of the outcome. And we're lucky in the United States because we get to, if the government's doing something you don't, you don't agree with or you don't like or you don't, you want it to be different,
这太疯狂了。就像，很酷，你知道的。但拜登总统在我参加的一次国情咨文演讲中肯定说过的一件事是，你不能只在你想赢的人获胜时才去爱我们的国。就像，我们必须，你知道的，无论结果如何，我们都要对我们的国家保持尊重和热爱。在美国，我们很幸运，因为如果我们觉得政府做的事情你不同意、或者你不喜欢、或者你不希望这样、你想让它变得不同，
you can do something about it. So on our first episode of the show, we talked to Nicole Hannah-Jones a lot about the preamble. So we the people. And one of the things we talked about a lot was we the people didn't include her when it was written because she was black. But she, you know, still engages with the open-ended promise of the Constitution. And so it's pretty interesting that slaves in slavery are not mentioned in the Constitution, even though a lot of it is written around slavery. But one thing that struck me in Article 1 is that Indians are explicitly named in Article 1 as people excluded from being counted in the census to determine representation. So obviously, you are here. You are a U.S. representative. Times have changed. But when you read the Constitution, how do you take that mention? And like, how do you
你就可以为此做点什么。所以在我们节目的第一集里，我们和尼科尔·汉娜-琼斯深入探讨了序言。也就是“我们人民”（We the people）。我们讨论得最多的其中一点是，当序言撰写时，“我们人民”并没有把她包括在内，因为她是黑人。但她（你知道的）仍然致力于践行宪法那开放式的承诺。所以非常有趣的是，奴隶制和奴隶在宪法中甚至没有被提及，尽管其中很大一部分内容都是围绕奴隶制编写的。但我在第一条中注意到的一件事是，印第安人在第一条中被明确点名，作为被排除在计算众议院席位的人口普查之外的人。所以很显然，你现在在这里。你是一名美国众议员。时代已经变了。但当你阅读宪法时，你是如何看待这一提及的？以及，你是如何将这一点
sort of incorporate that into how you operate as representative? Well, I think so a couple of things. I think probably because of, again, like growing up as an army brat, you know, and it wasn't just my mom that was in, the army. It was my grandfather I have like there's actually like so many people from my tribe who have served in the military and
某种程度上融入到你作为众议员的履职方式中的？嗯，我认为——所以有几点。我想可能因为，再次强调，就像在军人家庭长大一样（你知道的），而且不仅仅是我妈妈在军队，还有我外公。我有——实际上有好多来自我部落的人都在军队服役，并在
various branches and so I think because of just like my experience growing up I kind of just always thought of our country as a work in progress like I've just kind of always thought like well yeah when
各个兵种中。所以我认为，仅仅因为我成长的经历，我基本上总是把我们的国家看作是一个仍在进行中的工程——我基本上总是觉得，好吧，是的，当
the country first started like these like this is all the stuff that I'm glad we were able to change you know I got elected less than a hundred years after native people were recognized as citizens of this country so because that happened in 2024 because in 1924 in June of 1924 is when the Indian Citizenship Act passed and so I think that you know in my mind it's kind of it was kind of like oh and it's not a natural progression It's a progression, but it's not a natural progression. It's one that has to be, it has to be cultivated and grown and supported and fought for depending on what types of progress we're talking about.
这个国家刚开始时，这些——这些都是我很高兴我们能够改变的东西，你知道的。我当选时距离原住民被承认拥有这个国家的公民身份还不到一百年。因为那发生在2024年（编者注：应为1924年）——因为在1924年，1924年6月，《印第安人公民身份法》通过了。所以我认为，你知道的，在我的脑海里，它有点像——而且这不是一个自然的演变。这是一个演变，但它不是一个自然发生的演变。这是一个必须被耕耘、被培育、被支持、并为之奋斗的演变，这取决于我们所讨论的是哪种类型的进步。
And so to me, it's like, you know, I mean, it kind of feels like, you know, when I went to law school, so I got into Cornell, people are always like, how did you choose Cornell? And I'm like, well, they let me in. That's how I chose it. Yeah. But I remember feeling really insecure about going, I'm like, oh, I'm going to go to the East Coast, don't be all Kansas, in New York. And then I was like, oh, I'm not even in a city like I'm in Ithaca, which is like a college town. And then I remember just feeling really insecure about the fact that like all, I was like, all these people that are going to be there went probably went to private schools and they, you know, like their parents are lawyers or just. like, went to private schools for, like, all of their lives and to some kind of big-wig private college or university or whatever. So I had all these thoughts in my head. And then I also was like, but we're in the same place now. So what does it matter? Like, you know, we're in the same place now. And, and it's not to say that the beginning part of this country doesn't matter. It
所以对我来说，这就好像——你知道的，这有点像我当年去法学院的时候，我被康奈尔大学录取了，人们总是问：“你怎么选择康奈尔的？”我说：“嗯，因为他们录取了我。这就是我选择它的原因。”是的。但我记得当时去的时候感到非常没有安全感，我想：“哦，我要去东海岸了，别表现得太像堪萨斯州人那样，这里是纽约。”然后我想：“哦，我甚至不在一个大城市里，我在伊萨卡，那是一个大学城。”然后我记得我当时感到非常没有安全感，因为我觉得所有——我想，所有这些要去那里的人可能都上过私立学校，而且他们（你知道的）他们的父母都是律师，或者就是那种一辈子都上私立学校，然后去某种大人物私立学院或大学之类地方的人。所以我脑子里有所有这些想法。然后我又想：“但我们现在在同一个地方了。所以这有什么大不了的？”就像，你知道的，“我们现在在同一个地方了。”这并不是说这个国家的开端不重要，它
matters a lot. But we're in the same place now. Like, this is the place we're in now. You know, 105 years ago, I wouldn't have been even considered an American. And now I'm in Congress. And all I can do is make sure to do as much with the time and the place that we're at right now as I can. And, you know, and I think there's a lot of us in this country who are doing that. Well, Representative Davids, thank you so much for taking the time to talk to us. Thank you so much. It was wonderful. Yeah. Oh, my God. This is like one of the more fun things I've done.
非常重要。但我们现在在同一个地方了。就像，这就是我们现在身处的地方。你知道的，105年前，我甚至都不会被当作一个美国人看待。而现在我在国会。我能做的全部事情，就是确保充分利用我们现在所处的这个时间和地点，尽我所能做到最好。而且，你知道的，我认为这个国家有很多像我们这样的人正在这样做。嗯，戴维斯众议员，非常感谢您抽出时间与我们交谈。非常感谢。太棒了。是的。哦，天哪。这是我做过的更有趣的事情之一。
It was delightful. I really, really appreciate it. That was great. Thanks. We have more about an Article 1 power that's vested in Congress, but not explicitly listed by name. I'm talking about tariffs, people. Tariffs. Strap in after this. Each month after our book club breakdown section with our guest, Elizabeth is going to use constitutional law to explain something in the news. So it is Tuesday, September 23rd, 10.40 a.m. as we are recording this, what are we going to be talking about today? All right, Roman, today let's start with the opening lines of a novel. So here goes. Ours is essentially a tragic age, so we refuse to take it tragically. The cataclysm has happened. We are among the ruins. We start to build up new little habits to have new little hopes.
这太令人愉快了。我真的、真的很感激。太棒了。谢谢。关于国会所拥有的一项第一条权力，我们还有更多要聊的，虽然它没有被明确点名。我说的是关税，各位。关税。听完这个请系好安全带。在我们与嘉宾的读书俱乐部剖析环节之后，每个月伊丽莎白都将运用宪法法律来解释新闻中的某件事。因此，在我们录制这期节目的当下，时间是9月23日星期二上午10点40分，我们今天要聊些什么呢？好的，罗曼，今天我们先从一部小说的开篇名句开始。内容是这样的：本质上，我们身处一个悲剧的时代，所以我们拒绝以悲剧的眼光看待它。大灾难已经发生。我们身处废墟之中。我们开始建立新的小习惯，怀抱新的小希望。
So, Roman, are you familiar with the novel Lady Chatterley's Lever? No. Okay. Well, if you've never read it, Lady Chatterley's Lever is a novel written by the British author David Herbert Lawrence in 1928. D.H. Lawrence. Right. And the plot revolves around an affair between an upper-class woman, Lady Chatterley, and a working-class man, Oliver Miller's, her gamekeeper. So despite the abstract nature of the beginning of the novel,
那么，罗曼，你熟悉小说《查泰莱夫人的情人》吗？不熟悉。好吧。如果你没读过的话，《查泰莱夫人的情人》是英国作家大卫·赫伯特·劳伦斯于1928年创作的一部小说。D·H·劳伦斯。没错。其情节围绕着一位上流社会女性查泰莱夫人与一个工人阶级男子、她的游戏看守人奥利弗·梅勒斯之间的婚外情展开。因此，尽管小说开篇的性质比较抽象，
novel. It's a very sexually explicit novel. Of the things I know, that's what I know. You're right. And it's controversial for that explicitness. Lady Chatterley's Lever was subjected to bans in different countries for being indecent or obscene. And in fact, British readers could not actually buy the novel legally until 1960, at which point it became a bestseller and remains an influential work of literature. And it also became the subject of heated debate on the full. of the U.S. Senate in March of 1930. The question was, how obscene was this book?
小说。这是一部非常具有性描写的小说。在我所知道的常识里，这就是我所知道的。你说得对。它也因为这种直白露骨而备受争议。《查泰莱夫人的情人》因为被认为有伤风化或淫秽而在不同国家遭到禁售。事实上，英国读者直到1960年才真正合法的买到这部小说，当时它成了一本畅销书，并且至今仍是一部具有影响力的文学作品。它还成为了1930年3月美国参议院全会上激烈辩论的主题。问题是：这本书到底有多淫秽？
And in the eyes of some senators, vary. In fact, one senator stood on the Senate floor and stated that Lady Chatterley's lever was so disgusting, so dirty, and vile, that the reading of one page was enough for me. And the debate wasn't just about D.H. Lawrence's novel. The senator targeted all so-called obscene books. He said, I want them all kept out.
在一些参议员看来，极其淫秽。事实上，有一位参议员站在参议院大厅里宣称，《查泰莱夫人的情人》是如此令人作呕、如此肮脏和卑劣，以至于读上一页就足够让我受够了。而且这场辩论不仅仅是关于D·H·劳伦斯的小说的。这位参议员将矛头指向了所有所谓淫秽的书籍。他说：“我希望把它们全都拒之门外。”
I want to say to the senators now that a father of a child would never want the child to see this obscene matter. They are disgusting. They are beastly. Beasily. You see, the Senate was debating a proposed change to existing law, and federal law at the time allowed customs officials to ban literature they considered indecent or obscene from entering the country. Senator Bronson Cutting from New Mexico supported an amendment to eliminate this censorship in the name of free speech. You know, he argued that censors trampled on freedom of thought. And as Senator Cutting observed, you could buy plenty of racy literature at your local stores.
“我要对现在的参议员们说，一个孩子的父亲绝不会想让孩子看到这些淫秽内容。它们令人作呕。它们极其野蛮。野蛮。”你看，当时参议院正在辩论一项对现行法律的拟议修改，当时的联邦法律允许海关官员禁止他们认为有伤风化或淫秽的文学作品进入该国。来自新墨西哥州的参议员布朗森·卡廷支持一项旨在以言论自由的名义消除这种审查制度的修正案。你知道的，他辩称审查制度践踏了思想自由。正如卡廷参议员所观察到的那样，你可以在当地商店买到大量耸人听闻的文学作品。
He listed titles like Joy Stories, Paris Nights, Hot Dog, Hot Lines for Flaming Youth, Jim Jam Jems, and Whiz Bang. but Cutting's opponent wasn't having it. He said, if I were a customs inspector, this obscene literature would only be admitted over my dead body. I'd rather have a child of mine use opium than read these books. The debate packed the Senate galleries and titillated journalists, and the attempt to lift the censorship of this obscene literature failed. Indecent literature imported into the country would continue to be seized. The winner of the debate,
他列举了诸如《欢乐故事》、《巴黎之夜》、《热狗》、《给炽热青年的热门台词》、《吉姆·杰姆·杰姆斯》和《威兹·班格》等书名。但卡廷的反对者可不买账。他说：“如果我是海关检查员，这些淫秽文学只有从我的尸体上踏过去才能被放行。我宁愿让我的孩子吸食鸦片，也不愿让他们读这些书。”这场辩论挤满了参议院旁听席，并让记者们兴奋不已，而解除对这些淫秽文学审查的尝试最终失败了。进口到该国的有伤风化文学作品将继续被查封。这场辩论的胜利者，
though Senator who said Lady Chatterley's Lever was Beasley, his name was Reed Smoot, Senator from Utah. And Smoot's performance was so widely covered that it generated headlines like Smoot Smites Smut. And in 1931, Ogden Nash mocked the Senator with this poem.
尽管这位参议员说《查泰莱夫人的情人》是淫秽的，但他的名字叫里德·斯穆特，是来自犹他州的参议员。斯穆特的表现得到了广泛报道，以至于引发了诸如《斯穆特痛击淫秽》之类的头条新闻。1931年，奥格登·纳什用这首诗嘲讽了这位参议员。
Senator Smoot is an institute not to be bribed with Pelf. He guards our homes from erotic tomes by reading them all himself. Smite, smoot, smut for Ute, they're smuggling smut from Balt to Butte. Strongest and sternest of your sex, scatter the scoundrels from can to mex. The debate was a colorful highlight of an otherwise pretty boring subject. The censorship amendment was part of a larger bill that it started in the House Ways and Means Committee, chaired by Representative Willis Hawley of Oregon.
斯穆特参议员不是一个能用贿赂收买的机构。他通过自己阅读来保护我们的家园免受色情书籍的侵害。痛击，斯穆特，犹他州的淫秽物品，他们正把淫秽物品从巴尔的摩走私到比尤特。你性别中最强大、最严厉的人，把无赖从头到尾赶走。这场辩论是一个原本相当无聊的主题中的一个丰富多彩的亮点。这项审查修正案是一项更大法案的一部分，该法案始于众议院筹款委员会，由俄勒冈州众议员威利斯·霍利主持。
That bill originally intended to help farmers eventually levied tariffs on more than 20,000 imported goods by an average of 20%. Now, economists generally agree that the bill, signed into law by President Herbert Hoover in June of 1930, made the conditions of the Great Depression even worse. the law would come to be remembered not as the tariff act of 1930, but the Smoot-Hawley Act. You know, the question the teacher asked in the 1986 film, Ferris Fuehler's Day Off. You remember that? I do. Yeah.
该法案最初旨在帮助农民，最终对2万多种进口商品平均征收了20%的关税。现在，经济学家普遍认为，由小赫伯特·霍华德总统于1930年6月签署成为法律的这项法案，使大萧条的状况变得更加糟糕。这项法律后来被人们记住的不是1930年的关税法，而是斯穆特-霍利法案。你知道，老师在1986年电影《春天不是读书天》中提出的那个问题。你还记得吗？我记得。是的。
We says, anyone, anyone, anyone, anyone, the tariff bill, anyone? Raised or lowered, raised tariffs. Right. Anyone raised, raised tariffs? Well, Smoot-Hawley is back in the news because President Trump, like Senator Smoot, is very fond of tariffs. So Trump has decided to impose lots of them. But can Trump impose these tariffs in the same way? Is he allowed to do that?
他说，任何人，任何人，任何人，任何人，关税法案，任何人？提高还是降低，提高关税。对。任何人提高，提高关税？好吧，斯穆特-霍利法案再次成为新闻，因为特朗普总统和斯穆特参议员一样，非常喜欢关税。所以特朗普决定征收很多关税。但是特朗普能以同样的方式征收这些关税吗？他被允许这样做吗？
Yeah, that's a good question. What does the Constitution say about this? Well, tariffs aren't actually in the Constitution, but remember, tariffs are taxes on imported goods. And Article 1 of the Constitution gives Congress the power to lay and collect taxes, duties, imposes, and excises. And Article 1 also gives Congress the power to regulate commerce with foreign nations. So the framers were very explicit about giving Congress the specific power to impose tariffs, which are taxes on goods. And that power was extremely important during the 18th and 19th centuries because tariffs
是的，这是一个好问题。宪法对此是怎么说的？好吧，关税实际上并不在宪法中，但请记住，关税是对进口商品征收的税。宪法第一条赋予国会征收税款、关税、捐税和消费税的权力。宪法第一条还赋予国会监管与外国商业往来的权力。因此，制定者非常明确地赋予国会征收关税（即对商品征收的税）的特定权力。这种权力在18和19世纪极其重要，因为关税
were the main source of revenue for the federal government. But tariffs can be a kind of unpredictable source of federal funding. They go up, they go down, and if tariff revenues decline, that means fiscal instability for the federal government. And that's part of the reason why Congress imposed the first income tax in 1816. and it's the ratification of the 16th Amendment in 1913 that ultimately gives Congress the constitutional power to impose a nationwide income tax. And from that point forward, it's income tax, not tariffs, that becomes the main basis of funding the federal government. But tariffs didn't disappear completely.
是联邦政府收入的主要来源。但关税可能是一种有些不可预测的联邦资金来源。它们时涨时跌，如果关税收入下降，就意味着联邦政府的财政不稳定。这也是国会在1816年征收第一笔所得税的部分原因，正是1913年第十六修正案的批准，最终赋予了国会征收全国性所得税的宪法权力。从那时起，成为联邦政府主要资金来源的是所得税，而不是关税。但关税并没有完全消失。
Like in 1930, when a Republican majority Congress tried to protect agricultural interests and then many other interests by passing the Smoot-Hawley Act. And of course, tariffs aren't just a means of raising revenue, right? They're also economic policy. And that's the main reason tariffs exist today, not to make money, but to be part of how the United States has trade relations with the rest of the world. And the Smoot-Hawley Act was just bad economic policy. It was an extremely protectionist law. As a result of the Smoot-Hawley Act, other countries imposed their own retaliatory tariffs on American goods. And by 1932, U.S. exports and imports fell by all. almost 70 percent, and both Smoot and Holly were voted out of office. Even though the Smoot-Hawley Act was a terrible policy, it was a straightforward use of Congress's power. The law passed a set of tariffs and specified tariffs in something like 95 pages of tariff schedules. So if this is Congress's job, how is it the president gets involved in this? Like, that's what happening right now. So there are two developments that are really useful to Noah's background.
就像在1930年，当一个共和党多数的国会试图通过通过《斯穆特-霍利法案》来保护农业利益以及许多其他利益时。当然，关税不仅仅是增加收入的一种手段，对吧？它们也是经济政策。这也是今天存在关税的主要原因，不是为了赚钱，而是成为美国与世界其他地区进行贸易关系的一部分。《斯穆特-霍利法案》简直是一项糟糕的经济政策。这是一项极具保护主义色彩的法律。由于《斯穆特-霍利法案》，其他国家对美国商品实施了报复性关税。到1932年，美国的出口和进口下降了几乎70%，斯穆特和霍利都被投票赶出了办公室。尽管《斯穆特-霍利法案》是一项糟糕的政策，但它是对国会权力的一种直接行使。该法案通过了一套关税，并在大约95页的关税表中具体规定了关税。所以，如果这是国会的工作，总统怎么会卷入其中呢？就像现在正在发生的事情一样。所以有两个进展对于了解背景真的很有用。
Since tariffs today really serve the purpose of global economic policy, that's a really complex job just for Congress to do. And one response is Congress creating things like the Nonpartisan International Trade Commission in 1916. Another response is to give some of its own authority through legislation to the president. So what this means is that Congress is giving the president limited powers to impose or suspend tariffs through international agreements. with other countries. Now, the second important development to understand is the use of emergency powers by the president. So let's talk about that 1917 trading with the Enemy Act, okay?
既然今天的关税真正服务于全球经济政策的目的，对于国会来说，这是一项非常复杂的工作。应对措施之一是国会在1916年创建了诸如无党派国际贸易委员会之类的机构。另一个应对措施是通过立法将自己的一些权力授予总统。这意味着国会正在通过与世界其他国家的国际协议，赋予总统征收或暂停关税的有限权力。现在，第二个需要了解的重要进展是总统对紧急权力的使用。所以让我们来谈谈1917年的《对敌贸易法》，好吗？
Okay. So that law allowed the president to decide whether to impose certain kinds of economic penalties on foreign transactions if the president declares that there's a national emergency. So this act, the trading with the enemy act, is a significant expansion of presidential power. It was used by many presidents in the post-World War II era. So, for instance, President Truman relied on the Act to impose economic sanctions on North Korea and China in 1950. But it was Nixon's use of the Act in the 1970s that eventually causes a problem. It's always Nixon.
好的。所以该法案允许总统在宣布国家紧急状态的情况下，决定是否对外国交易实施某些类型的经济惩罚。因此，这项法案，即《对敌贸易法》，是总统权力的一次重大扩张。第二次世界大战后的许多总统都使用过它。例如，杜鲁门总统在1950年依据该法对朝鲜和中国实施了经济制裁。但正是尼克松在20世纪70年代对该法的使用最终引发了一个问题。总是尼克松。
Yeah, it's talking about Nixon. Right. So in 1972, Nixon used the law to impose a 10% tariff on all imported goods as part of a set of economic measures to fight inflation. It's the 1970s. There's high inflation. There's a potential currency crisis in the United States. And Nixon's use of the trading with the Enemies Act to impose these tariffs is challenged in court, but eventually upheld. But, you know, that raises a question. Who really has the tariff power? Is it the president or Congress? And it's that legal fight that leads Congress to reform the emergency powers available to the president. And one of the things Congress does is in 1977, they pass a law called the International Emergency Economic Powers Act, also known as AEPA.
是的，在谈论尼克松。对。所以在1972年，尼克松利用该法律对所有进口商品征收10%的关税，作为对抗通货膨胀的一套经济措施的一部分。那是20世纪70年代。通货膨胀率很高。美国存在潜在的货币危机。尼克松利用《对敌贸易法》征收这些关税的做法在法庭上受到质疑，但最终得到了维持。但是，你知道，这引发了一个问题。到底谁拥有关税权力？是总统还是国会？正是这场法律斗争促使国会改革了总统可用的紧急权力。国会采取的行动之一是在1977年通过了一项名为《国际紧急经济权力法》的法律，也称为IEPA。
That's a terrible name, but I think we're going to have to use it. Okay. AEPA. Okay. So what does Aipa do? Well, with Aipa, Congress is still granting some of its authority to the president. But the law says two things important to understand what's happening now. First, the law says that the president of the United States can use AEPA to deal with any unusual
这是一个糟糕的名字，但我认为我们不得不使用它。好的。IEPA。好的。那么IEPA是做什么的呢？好吧，有了IEPA，国会仍然在向总统授予一些权力。但该法律指出了对于理解当前情况至关重要的两点。首先，法律规定美国总统可以使用IEPA来应对来自国外的任何异常
and extraordinary threat coming from outside of the country. And that can be a national security threat, a foreign policy threat, or even an economic threat so long as the president declares a national emergency. The second thing to keep in mind is that if the president declares a national emergency, one of the things the president is allowed to do under AEPA is to regulate importation or exportation of goods. So with AEPA, Congress is trying to be much more specific and limiting. in the kind of power it's giving to the president.
和非同寻常的威胁。只要总统宣布进入国家紧急状态，这就可以是国家安全威胁、外交政策威胁，甚至是经济威胁。需要记住的第二件事是，如果总统宣布进入国家紧急状态，总统根据IEPA获准做的事情之一就是监管商品的进口或出口。因此，通过IEPA，国会正试图在赋予总统的权力类型上变得更加具体和限制性。
Since 1977, presidents of both parties have relied on AIPA dozens of times. And so in the past, they've done things like ban transactions with a specific country or to freeze assets with a foreign entity because there's some declared national emergency. And so even though Aipa is considered an attempt by Congress to reign in presidential power, it's still an example of Congress trying to give the president some emergency authority. So part of the problem is that IEPA doesn't really define what a national emergency is, right? Totally. Or what an unusual and extraordinary threat to national security or foreign policy is?
自1977年以来，两党总统已经多次依赖IEPA。因此在过去，他们做过诸如禁止与特定国家的交易或由于宣布了某种国家紧急状态而冻结与外国实体的资产等事情。因此，尽管IEPA被认为是国会试图控制总统权力的一种尝试，但它仍然是国会试图赋予总统一些紧急权力的一個例子。所以部分问题在于IEPA并没有真正定义什么是国家紧急状态，对吧？完全正确。或者什么是对国家安全或外交政策的不寻常和非同寻常的威胁？
Well, one way to curb that is that federal law also allows Congress to terminate an emergency through a joint resolution, even if the president doesn't agree. But on the other hand, Congress has never once terminated an emergency declaration under IEPA against the wishes of a president. So is Trump relying on AEPA to do the tariffs that he's imposing right now? So a lot of the tariffs do fall under AEPA. So as soon as Trump started his second term, he issues a series of executive orders on tariffs, a lot of tariffs. You might have heard about tariffs on specific industries like steel and aluminum, but we're going to put those aside for now. The ones we want to talk about today fall into two types. First, there are the so-called trafficking tariffs.
好吧，遏制这一现象的一种方法是，联邦法律还允许国会通过联合决议终止紧急状态，即使总统不同意。但另一方面，国会从未有过一次在违背总统意愿的情况下根据IEPA终止紧急状态宣言。那么特朗普是否正依靠IEPA来实施他目前正在征收的关税？因此，许多关税确实属于IEPA的管辖范围。因此，特朗普一开启他的第二个任期，他就发布了一系列关于关税的行政命令，很多关税。你可能听说过针对钢铁和铝等特定行业的关税，但我们现在先把这些放在一边。我们主要想谈的关税分为两种。首先，是所谓的贩运关税。
Trump announced these by executive order on February 1st, and these are tariffs imposed on products from Canada, Mexico, and China. And then there are the worldwide or reciprocal tariffs. This is a tariff of at least 10% on basically every country we trade with. These tariffs were imposed on April 2nd by executive order. And some of these tariffs are even higher, as high as 50% in some countries. And to make things even more confusing, certainly for me, many of these tariffs have been altered or changed or suspended temporarily several times. So it's really hard to figure out which tariffs are in place right now. So why does Trump claim that he can use IEPA, you know, to do like a worldwide reciprocal tariff on like the entire world? We can't be
特朗普在2月1日的行政命令中宣布了这些关税，这些是对来自加拿大、墨西哥和中国的商品征收的关税。然后是全球或互惠关税。这是对我们与之进行贸易的基本上每个国家征收至少10%的关税。这些关于关税的行政命令是于4月2日颁布的。其中一些关税甚至更高，对某些国家高达50%。为了让事情变得更加令人困惑，对我来说肯定也是如此，许多此类关税已经被多次修改、变更或临时中止。因此，很难弄清楚目前究竟有哪些关税正在生效。那么为什么特朗普声称他可以使用IEPA，你知道的，对整个世界实施像全球互惠关税这样的东西？我们不可能
an emergency with the entire world, can we? Right. So Trump is relying on ambiguity, right? First, he's claiming that imposing a tariff in this way or a set of tariffs is part of what it means to regulate under Aipa, because that's the word in the statute. And second, Trump is claiming that there are two emergencies here. Remember, this is an emergency power. And one emergency is allegedly that Canada, Mexico, and China are not doing enough to stop the flow of illegal fentanyl into the United States. The other emergency, again, according to Trump, is the ongoing trade deficit between the United States and other countries. In April, a group of small businesses and a group of states, sued in a special court called the Court of International Trade, and they tried to challenge
与整个世界处于紧急状态，对吧？对的。所以特朗普依赖的是模棱两可的说法，对吧？首先，他声称以这种方式征收关税或一系列关税是根据IEPA进行监管的含义的一部分，因为那是法规中的词。其次，特朗普声称这里存在两个紧急状态。请记住，这是一项紧急权力。其中一个紧急状态据称是加拿大、墨西哥和中国在阻止非法芬太尼流入美国方面做得不够。另一个紧急状态，同样根据特朗普的说法，是美国与其他国家之间持续存在的贸易逆差。4月，一群小企业和一群州在名为国际贸易法院的特殊法庭起诉，他们试图挑战
Trump's use of IEPA to impose these specific tariffs. These two cases can be considered together. And what were their arguments in the Court of International Trade? So it's actually a really simple argument. Does Aipa allow this? They're saying no. There's no question that with Aipa, Congress has definitely given the president the ability to do a lot of things once an emergency has been declared. But there's no mention of the word tariff. in Aipa. So the question is, does the power to regulate, which is in the statute, does that include the power to impose tariffs? And then a secondary question could be something like, even if the president could do this, is something like the existence of a trade deficit with
特朗普使用IEPA来征收这些特定关税的做法。这两个案件可以合并审理。他们在国际贸易法院的论点是什么？所以这实际上是一个非常简单的论点。IEPA允许这样做吗？他们的回答是否定的。毫无疑问，有了IEPA，国会确实赋予了总统在宣布紧急状态后做很多事情的能力。但IEPA中根本没有提到“关税”这个词。所以问题是，法规中包含的监管权力是否包括征收关税的权力？然后第二个问题可能是，即使总统可以这样做，诸如与
other countries, something that's been going on for decades? Does that really count as an emergency under the statute? That's another kind of issue. Yeah. And so what's the status of this case? Because that seems like a pretty fundamental argument about presidential powers and stuff. figure that stuff out, right? Yeah. So in May of this year, the Court of International Trade, that's where the case was first filed, ruled against the Trump administration. The three judge panel in the case decided that Trump didn't have the authority to use AIPA in this way. The Trump administration appealed that decision. And at the end of August, the federal appeals court also decided against the Trump administration for basically the same reason. Trump does not
其他国家的贸易逆差这种已经持续了几十年的事情，真的算得上是法规下的紧急状态吗？这是另一种问题。是的。那么这个案件的现状如何？因为这似乎是一个关于总统权力等方面的相当基础的论点。弄清楚这些事情，对吧？是的。今年5月，最初提起诉讼的国际贸易法院做出了不利于特朗普政府的裁决。该案的三名法官小组裁定特朗普没有权力以这种方式使用IEPA。特朗普政府对该裁决提起了上诉。在8月底，联邦上诉法院也基本上以同样的理由做出了不利于特朗普政府的裁决。特朗普并不
have the authority under AIPA to impose these tariffs. Tariffs are presumptively Congress's responsibility, not the presidents. Then the Trump administration appealed this decision, and on September 9th, the Supreme Court agreed to hear the case. And the court has fast-tracked the case and has agreed to hear arguments in the case on November 5th. So, but what's really at stake with this case? Because this, I mean, this isn't just about tariffs. Declaring emergencies and doing things that should be Congress's job seems like Trump's ammo across the board. So what, you know, like what are the implications of all this? Well, of course, the tariffs themselves are a big deal.
拥有根据IEPA征收这些关税的权力。关税理应是国会的责任，而不是总统的。然后特朗普政府对这一裁决提起了上诉，9月9日，最高法院同意审理此案。法院加快了审理进程，并同意在11月5日听取该案的辩论。那么，这个案件真正处于危险中的是什么？因为这意味着，这不仅仅是关于关税。宣布紧急状态并做本该是国会工作的事情，似乎成了特朗普各方面的王牌。所以，你知道，这一切的含义是什么？好吧，当然，关税本身就是一件大事。
Of course, yeah. If you're a business or you're a consumer, the lawfulness of these big tariffs are of immense importance. Tariffs are a tax and we pay those taxes through higher prices on the things we buy. But the case is also going to have very big implications for the power of the presidency because it's now up to the Supreme Court. Does Trump have the power to do this? The Supreme Court could say, well, look, Trump lacks the authority under AIPA. he can't impose tariffs this way. They could interpret the statute and decide that the word regulate does not include the power
当然，是的。如果你是一家企业或一个消费者，这些大额关税的合法性具有极其重要的意义。关税是一种税，我们通过对购买的商品支付更高的价格来缴纳这些税。但该案件也将对总统的权力产生非常大的影响，因为现在要由最高法院来决定了。特朗普有权这样做吗？最高法院可能会说，看，特朗普缺乏来自IEPA的授权，他不能以这种方式征收关税。他们可以解释该法规并决定“监管”一词不包括
to impose tariffs. That would be the end of that. But if the court sides with Trump, then this would be a major expansion of presidential power. Trump has said that invalidating his tariffs will literally destroy the United States of America. Spoiler, it would not. But there is a very big question at the heart of the case. And because the case, which is now called VOS Select. versus Trump focuses on how the Supreme Court will interpret AEPA, which is a federal statute.
征收关税的权力。那就到此为止了。但如果法院站在特朗普一边，那么这将是对总统权力的重大扩张。特朗普曾表示，废除他的关税将从字面上摧毁美利坚合众国。剧透一下，并不会。但案件的核心存在一个非常大的重大问题。由于该案（现在被称为VOS Select诉特朗普案）侧重于最高法院将如何解释IEPA这一联邦法规，
There's a connection between the tariff case and student loan forgiveness. Oh, okay. Tell me more. That was out of left field for me, but okay. I'm following along. Let's go. Here we go. So during the height of the pandemic, the federal Department of Education suspended loan repayments for everybody who was paying back their federal student loans. Many people weren't working at home, so if you're not working, you can't pay back your loans. It seemed really unfair to make people try and repay them when everybody was stuck at home. Remember that student loan debt is a huge policy issue, whether or not you have the pandemic. Americans owe something like $1.6 trillion in student loan debt, and a lot of those loans are loans guaranteed by the federal government. So in August of 2022, the Biden administration announced a major student loan forgiveness program.
关税案与学生贷款减免之间存在着某种联系。哦，好吧。跟我多讲讲。这对我来说有点出乎意料，但好吧。我正跟着听呢。我们走吧。我们开始吧。在大流行的高峰期，联邦教育部暂停了所有偿还联邦学生贷款的人的贷款偿还。许多人不在家工作，所以如果你不工作，你就无法偿还贷款。当每个人都被困在家里的让人们试图偿还贷款，似乎真的很不公平。请记住，无论你是否有大流行，学生贷款债务都是一个巨大的政策问题。美国人欠下了大约1.6万亿美元的学生贷款债务，其中许多贷款是联邦政府担保的贷款。因此，在2022年8月，拜登政府宣布了一项重大学生贷款减免计划。
And that program was pretty straightforward. Every borrower who made less than $125,000 received $10,000 of loan forgiveness. So as we've been talking about, most of the money business of the government is done by Congress. So why did Biden think he could do this? So Biden relied on the 2003 Higher Education Relief Opportunities for Students Act or the Heroes Act. And that law says that the Secretary of Education can waive or modify terms related to student financial aid if it is necessary in connection with a war or other military operation or national emergency. See, it's an emergency power.
那个计划相当直截了当。每个收入低于12.5万美元的借款人都可以获得1万美元的贷款豁免。正如我们一直在讨论的那样，政府的大部分资金业务都是由国会完成的。那么，为什么拜登认为他可以这样做呢？拜登依据的是2003年的《高等教育救济学生机遇法》，或称《英雄法案》。该法律规定，如果因战争、其他军事行动或国家紧急状态而有必要，教育部长可以免除或修改与学生经济资助相关的条款。看，这是一项紧急权力。
An earlier version of the Heroes Act was passed to help borrowers affected by the September 11th terrorist attack. So this goes way back. But the 2003 Heroes Act extended this coverage. Now, remember, in March of 2020, the president declared that the pandemic was a national emergency. Remember who the president was? In March of 2020? That was President Trump. That was President Trump.
《英雄法案》的早期版本是通过的，旨在帮助受9·11恐怖袭击影响的借款人。所以这可以追溯到很久以前。但2003年的《英雄法案》扩大了这一适用范围。现在，大家还记得，在2020年3月，总统宣布大流行是国家紧急状态。还记得当时总统是谁吗？在2020年3月？那是特朗普总统。那是特朗普总统。
Now, a group of states challenged the loan forgiveness program. And in 2023, the Supreme Court was asked to answer this question. When the Heroes Act says that the Secretary of Education, which is, of course, part of the executive branch, when the Secretary of Education can waive or modify student aid, does that include the power to forgive student loans? And the Supreme Court decided, no, it does not. And the reason why is important, because you see, over recent years, the conservative majority in the Supreme Court has been relying on what it calls the major questions doctrine. So let's talk about the major questions doctrine because this has been a thing that's been percolating up over the last few years. That's right. And so the idea behind the major questions doctrine is that if there's a dispute about what a federal statute means, let's say Congress puts in some ambiguous language and the disputed part of the statute, involves the executive branch trying to exercise a power involving deep economic and political
现在，有一群州对贷款豁免计划提出了质疑。在2023年，最高法院被要求回答这样一个问题：当《英雄法案》规定教育部长——当然他是行政分支的一部分——当教育部长可以免除或修改学生资助时，这是否包括豁免学生贷款的权力？最高法院裁定，不，并不包括。原因非常重要，因为大家知道，近年来，最高法院中的保守派多数一直依赖其所谓的重大问题原则。让我们来谈谈重大问题原则，因为这成了过去几年里一直在酝酿的一个问题。没错。因此，重大问题原则背后的理念是，如果对于一项联邦成文法意味着什么存在争议，比方说国会在争议法条中加入了一些模棱两可的语言，且法条中存在争议的部分涉及行政分支试图行使一项具有深远经济和政治意义的权力。
significance. The Supreme Court is not going to assume that that power is okay. The court will say, look, if Congress is going to give the executive branch some very big power, they have to be clear about it. We're not going to interpret the law to say the executive branch gets to exercise this major power unless Congress says so. And they really have to be clear about it. So in the Biden student loan forgiveness case, the Supreme Court relied on the major questions doctrine to say, look, the forgiveness of billions of dollars of student loans by the Department of Education is a huge issue. And if Congress had intended for this to be a real possibility for a president to do, they would have made the Heroes Act much more specific and clear about this. And so, no, major questions doctrine means Biden cannot
最高法院不会默认这种权力是没问题的。法院会说，听着，如果国会打算赋予行政分支某种非常重大的权力，他们必须对此表述得清清楚楚。除非国会明确表示，否则我们不会将法律解释为行政分支有权行使这一重大权力。而且他们必须说得非常清楚。因此，在拜登学生贷款豁免案中，最高法院依据重大问题原则指出，教育部豁免数百亿美元的学生贷款是一个极其重大问题。如果国会有意让总统真正有可能做到这一点，他们就会把《英雄法案》写得更加具体和明确。因此，不，重大问题原则意味着拜登不能
use the Heroes Act, which says you can waive or modify student federal financial assistance. Can't use it in this way to forgive student loans. And that's not the only case where the Supreme Court has found that Biden-era actions were not authorized by Congress. Huh. And so what does this mean for all the Trump cases? Well, if the Supreme Court's going to be consistent and the tariff case would also appear to pose a major questions doctrine problem. And that's because no president, no president before Trump has ever used AIPA in this way to impose tariffs around the world, meaning this is the very first time a president has used emergency economic powers to impose global, ongoing tariffs. So that would seem to implicate a question of
使用《英雄法案》——该法案规定可以免除或修改联邦学生经济资助。不能以这种方式使用它来豁免学生贷款。这并不是最高法院裁定拜登时期的行动未获国会授权的唯一案件。呵。那么，这对所有特朗普案意味着什么呢？嗯，如果最高法院要保持一致性，关税案似乎也会带来重大问题原则的问题。这是因为此前没有任何总统——特朗普之前的任何总统——曾以这种方式使用《国际紧急经济权力法》来在全球范围内征收关税，这意味着这是总统历史上第一次利用紧急经济权力来征收全球性的、持续的关税。因此，这似乎会引发一个
deep economic and political significance. A major question, you would say. That's right, a major question. But AIPA says only that the president can regulate importation. So if the words waive or modify do not mean cancel student loans under the Heroes Act, why should regulate mean tariff under AIPA, especially when many other federal laws specifically refer to the word tariff or the power to impose tariffs. Now, in the student loan case, the Supreme Court said that the Biden administration was, and I'm quoting here, modifying student loans only in the same sense that the French Revolution modified the status of the French nobility.
具有深远经济和政治意义的问题。你会说，这是一个重大问题。没错，这是一个重大问题。但《国际紧急经济权力法》仅规定总统可以规制进口。因此，如果“免除”或“修改”在《英雄法案》下不意味着“取消学生贷款”，为什么在《国际紧急经济权力法》下“规制”就应该意味着“征收关税”呢？特别是当许多其他联邦法律专门提到了“关税”一词或征收关税的权力时。现在，在学生贷款案中，最高法院表示，拜登政府——在此我引用原话——修改学生贷款的方式，只相当于法国大革命修改法国贵族地位的意义相同。
Oh, my God. Okay. And so in the tariff case, the federal appeals court used the same reasoning to say that Trump can't impose these tariffs. They're of unlimited duration on imports of nearly all goods from nearly every country with which the United States conducts trade. That was a transformative, unprecedented power. And President Trump just didn't have the authority to do that.
天哪。好的。因此，在关税案中，联邦上诉法院使用了相同的推理来裁定特朗普不能征收这些关税。它们对来自几乎美国与之有贸易往来的每个国家的几乎所有商品的进口具有无限期的效力。那是一种变革性的、前所未有的权力。而特朗普总统根本没有这样做的权力。
So in other words, Trump's use of IEPA to impose global tariffs requires a major questions doctrine analysis. And if we're going to be consistent, it would seem that the tariffs have an uphill battle to climb if they're really going to fall under this emergency statute. If Congress intended for this worldwide tariff scheme to happen, well, shouldn't they have said so explicitly? And that's the question for the Supreme Court. will the justices consistently apply the cases of just a few years ago and decide that Trump lacks the authority to use a federal law in this unprecedented way? Or will they side with Trump because they side with Trump? The pattern of siding with Trump makes me fearful for the outcome of this case. Yeah. I mean, there's lots to be worried about because in a lot of cases
换句话说，特朗普利用《国际紧急经济权力法》征收全球关税需要进行重大问题原则分析。如果我们想要保持一致性，这些关税如果真的要归入这项紧急法案管辖，似乎将面临一场极其艰难的战斗。如果国会有意让这种全球关税计划发生，嗯，他们难道不应该明确说明这一点吗？这就是摆在最高法院面前的问题：法官们会始终如一地适用几年前的判例，并裁定特朗普无权以这种前所未有的方式动用联邦法律吗？还是说他们会站在特朗普一边，因为他们倾向于站在特朗普一边？倾向于支持特朗普的这种模式让我对本案的结果感到担忧。是的。我的意思是，有很多事情令人担忧，因为在许多情况下
it seems like that has the most explanatory power, right? That like how does, how can we explain what happened here. They seem to simply be siding with the Trump administration. Either way, it could be that the tariffs continue. I mean, the court could say that, yes, Trump has the power to use IEPA in this way, or, you know, the court could strike down this use, but then, you know, a lot of other folks have pointed out that Trump can rely on other statutes to impose tariffs. So tariffs might continue, but I think the real heart of the matter is, you know, what's going to happen to what seems to be an expanding office of the president. A lot of this began with, you know, Congress abdicating some of its responsibility here to the president so that emergency action could be taken in sort of in a good faith sense.
这似乎具有最强的解释力，对吧？就像我们如何解释这里发生的事情一样。他们似乎只是简单地站在特朗普政府一边。无论如何，关税可能会继续存在。我的意思是，法院可能会说，是的，特朗普有权以这种方式使用《国际紧急经济权力法》；或者，你知道，法院可能会驳回这种做法，但是，许多其他人已经指出，特朗普可以依赖其他法规来征收关税。因此，关税可能会继续下去，但我认为问题的核心是，你知道，这个似乎正在扩张的总统办公室将会发生什么。这很大程度上始于，你知道，国会将这里的一些责任放弃给总统，以便在某种善意的意义上采取紧急行动。
A lot of these roads that we go down are often when these three branches aren't defending their space the way that we kind of need them to for the structure of the Constitution to work. The one thing that gives me a little bit of comfort in this is that it seems that the major questions doctrine is a lot of the Supreme Court kind of standing up for itself and its role of determining these things and pushing Congress to do the things that it needs to do to sort of hold its place as an equal branch. in the interest of defending their role as the Supreme Court, as the arbiter of major questions, maybe they will be consistent here. It could be. I mean, that's the optimistic view, right? And then even if there is a check in the case, in the tariff case, when the Supreme Court ultimately decides it, you know, passing the ball to Congress, you know, we can only sort of hope that something works.
我们走过的许多这些道路，往往都是当这三个分支没有按照宪法结构发挥作用所需的那样去捍卫自己的空间时发生的。让我对此感到稍许安慰的一点是，重大问题原则似乎在很大程度上体现了最高法院挺身而出，捍卫其裁决这些事项的角色，并敦促国会做其需要做的事情，以保住其作为平等分支的地位。为了捍卫其作为最高法院、作为重大问题仲裁者的角色，也许他们会在这里保持一致。有可能。我的意思是，那是乐观的看法，对吧？然后，即使在这个案件中有了制衡，在关税案中，当最高法院最终做出裁决时，你知道，将皮球踢给国会，你知道，我们只能某种程度上希望事情能发挥作用。
I mean, the law itself actually gives Congress the ability to check the president, but they have not done so. And so we need everybody to kind of. get involved. That's right. I mean, but it also sort of seems like the sort of fig leaf with which the sort of expansive powers that the Supreme Court has been giving Trump is a little bit of like, well, this Congress should stop. You know, like then Congress passes a law. You know, like that's their job. But we have a sort of a complicit Congress who's just like in the pocket for Trump and so that it doesn't work that way. And my optimistic read is that the ideologies align here to sort of thwart Trump in this case to reserve more power to Congress.
我的意思是，法律本身实际上赋予了国会制衡总统的能力，但他们并没有这样做。所以我们需要每个人都参与进来。没错。我的意思是，但这也似乎有点像遮羞布，最高法院一直在赋予特朗普的那种扩张性权力，有点像，嗯，国会应该停止这样做。你知道，就像国会随后通过一项法律一样。你知道，就像那是他们的工作一样。但我们有一个同谋的国会，他们就像是被特朗普收买了一样，所以事情并不是那样运作的。我乐观的解读是，意识形态在这里达成了一致，从而在这个案件中挫败特朗普，为国会保留更多权力。
I don't know. Yeah, that could work. I mean, I think one of the ironies here is that Aipa, the very law that's at the heart of this case, is actually an attempt in the 1970s by Congress to try and claw back some power. But it absolutely hasn't worked this way at all. In fact, you know, folks have pointed out that presidents seem to declare emergencies all the time and then get to do whatever they want. Yeah.
我不知道。是的，那可能会起作用。我的意思是，我认为这里的讽刺意味之一是，《国际紧急经济权力法》——这个案件的核心法律——实际上是国会在20世纪70年代试图夺回部分权力的一种尝试。但它根本没有按这种方式发挥作用。事实上，你知道，人们指出，总统似乎一直在宣布进入紧急状态，然后就可以为所欲为。是的。
It's that word emergency. Like replacing the word emergency with the word emergency didn't seem like the most prudent. Because like, it's like, I don't know. I have emergencies every single day. My kids have emergencies about stuff that you wouldn't believe. Exactly. And that's part of the problem. That's part of the problem.
就是“紧急状态”这个词。就像把“紧急状态”这个词换成“紧急状态”似乎并不是最明智的做法。因为，就像，我不知道。我每天都有紧急状态。我的孩子们遇到的紧急状态，是你无法相信的事情。没错。这就是问题的一部分。这就是问题的一部分。
The word that doesn't exist in the Constitution, but everybody seems to be focused on. So I don't want to end on like a gloomy note, Roman. So before we end, why don't we go back to Lady Chatterley for a moment? Okay. There is a wonderful song mentioning it. from 1965 by Tom Lehrer that I thought we could end with. Maybe Roman, you could read the lyrics. The song is called Smut.
这个词在宪法中并不存在，但每个人似乎都专注于它。所以罗曼，我不想以悲观的基调结束。在我们结束之前，我们为什么不暂时回到《查泰莱夫人的情人》呢？好的。有一首美妙的歌提到了它，由汤姆·莱勒于1965年创作，我想我们可以用它来结尾。也许罗曼你可以读一下歌词。这首歌叫《下流》（Smut）。
Tom Laird, of course, who just passed away. I know. It's really, really like a national treasure as far as I'm concerned. Okay, so here it is. Who needs a hobby, likely tennis or philatily? I've got a hobby, rereading Lady Chatterley. But now they're trying to take it all away from us, unless we take a stand and hand in hand, we fight for the freedom of the press.
汤姆·莱勒，当然，他刚刚去世。我知道。就我而言，他真的，真的就像国宝一样。好的，歌词是这样的：谁需要业余爱好，比如网球或集邮？我有一个爱好，重读《查泰莱夫人的情人》。但现在他们试图把这一切从我们身边夺走，除非我们表明立场，携手并进，为新闻自由而战。
great that's so good yeah it's awesome what's fascinating to me here is like when we're talking about article one in the last section when we're doing our book club like the fights over article one seem to be the fights of our age you know what I mean right like what are the powers of Congress and what are the powers of the executive we haven't gotten to article two yet but it's like it's really something um to think about like what is enumerated what is not what is thought about what is not. But what is clear to me is that as I read it, the tone of Article 1 is that the tie goes to Congress almost all the time. That's what it reads to me like, right? But I think part of the problem is that, as you can see, you can't really talk about one branch without talking about the other
太棒了，太好了，是的，这太棒了。这里让我着迷的是，就像我们在最后一节讨论第一条时，当我们做读书俱乐部时，围绕第一条的争斗似乎是我们这个时代的争斗，你知道我的意思吗？对吧？就像国会的权力是什么，行政部门的权力是什么。我们还没谈到第二条，但就像，思考哪些是被列举的，哪些不是，什么是被考虑的，什么不是，这真的很重要，嗯。但对我来说显而易见的是，当我阅读它时，第一条的语气是，平局几乎总是判给国会。这就是我的读后感，对吧？但我认为部分问题在于，正如你所看到的，你今天真的无法在不谈论另一个分支的情况下谈论一个分支
today. Because when you talk about Article 1, you talk about a president who tries to take some of their power. And in fact, Congress has given the president some of this power. Why? Because in some ways in the 20th century, Congress realizes, you know, we can't really deal with all these things officially. But there's one person who can act quickly, and that's the president. So we'll give them some of our power. And it turns out to have all of these unintended consequences, or perhaps intended consequences. A president decides to run with that power and do much more than what Congress intended. Yeah. It's really set up for a revolutionary mindset that each branch would be defending its turf in a kind of way. Like, it's not. It's not.
因为当你谈论第一条时，你是在谈论一个试图夺取他们部分权力的总统。事实上，国会已经赋予了总统部分权力。为什么？因为在20世纪的某些方面，国会意识到，你知道，我们无法真正以官方身份处理所有这些事情。但有一个人可以迅速行动，那就是总统。所以我们将我们的一些权力分给他们。结果证明这带来了所有这些意料之外的后果，或者说可能是意料之中的后果。一位总统决定带着这种权力狂飙，做出远超国会意图的事情。是的。它确实为一种革命性的心态做好了准备，即每个分支都会以某种方式捍卫自己的地盘。就像，它不是。它不是。
made for a collusion across branches. It's really made for like Congress, even Congress, even like senators of the same party to be offended by presidential overreach. And when I read like the other Robert Caro books on Lyndon Johnson and stuff like this, like Democratic senators like take umbrage to, you know, to Johnson not just because they're racist and he's trying to like create the great society, but like also because of just that like the fundamental fact of overreach and powers is like, is like some. something that they just like immediately react to in a way that I just don't really see anymore. Yeah. I mean, I think this idea of like, I think you're referring to this idea of like
为了各分支之间的勾结而制造的。它实际上是为了让国会，甚至国会，甚至像同党参议员这样的人，对总统的越权行为感到冒犯而制造的。当我阅读罗伯特·卡罗关于林登·约翰逊及类似内容的其他书籍时，民主党参议员对约翰逊感到不满，不仅仅是因为他们是种族主义者而他正试图创建伟大社会，而是因为越权和权力的基本事实，就像是，是某种。他们会立刻做出反应的东西，而这种反应我真的再也看不到了。是的。我的意思是，我认为这个想法就像，我想你指的是这个想法
jealously guarding, you know, your branch. I mean, that definitely is not part of a major part of our conversations that we're seeing or having. In fact, there's just this extreme partisanship that seems to explain a lot of what's happening. And that's not the way we set up the separation of powers. It's called the separation of powers for a reason. Yeah. And so that's a kind of fatal collision, right? A Congress that decided decades ago to say, well, we'll be flexible with our authority and what, how we think of our powers and kind of transfer some of them to the executive. Now, what happens when you have extreme partisanship across two branches, maybe three? There is no interbranch checking going on. Right, right. I mean,
嫉妒般地捍卫，你知道，你所属的分支。我的意思是，这绝对不是我们正在看到或进行的对话的主要部分。事实上，存在着极端的党派偏见，这似乎解释了正在发生的大部分事情。这不是我们建立三权分立的方式。三权分立被称为三权分立是有原因的。是的。所以这是一种致命的冲突，对吧？一个在几十年前决定说“好吧，我们要对我们的权力和我们如何看待我们的权力保持灵活性，并将其中的一部分转移给行政部门”的国会。现在，当你在两个分支（也许是三个）之间存在极端党派偏见时会发生什么？没有任何分支间的制衡在发生。对，对。我的意思是，
it's sort of like, you know, like our whole criminal justice system is based on an adversarial system. And it wouldn't function if there was this great deal of collusion across the different adversarial like standpoints of criminal trial. Like it would be unfair and just unjust. You know, like it's adversarial for a reason. It's adversarial by design. And it seemed to be losing that when it comes to these powers and different branches. Yeah. I mean, basically what you see are two different conversations happening today, which is on the one hand, a kind of small group of people, yelling loudly that there's something wrong with the structure here, that the way things are supposed to work with checks are not working. And then most of the conversation are not caring
这有点像，你知道的，我们整个刑事司法系统都是基于对抗制系统的。如果刑事审判中不同的对抗立场之间存在如此巨大的勾结，它是无法运转的。那将是不公平和绝对不正义的。你知道，就像它出于某种原因具有对抗性。它在设计上就是对抗性的。而当涉及到这些权力和不同的分支时，它似乎正在失去这一点。是的。我的意思是，基本上你看到的是今天正在发生的两场不同的对话，一方面是一小群人，大声喊叫这里的结构出了问题，本应通过制衡发挥作用的方式没有发挥作用；然后大部分对话根本不关心
about that at all. Really just a results-oriented approach to the way the federal government works. And I mean, I think that that's a real failure to connect that the abstract structure helps people get to the substantive results that they voted for. We learned that in the last election, that this idea of the death of democracy or like our Democratic norms or eroding, wasn't really like that motivating of an idea. Right. It was just too much. It was too much classroom and not enough, you know, get out there and vote with your feet. Yeah. Thank you so much. Thanks, Rowling. Join us next month. We're continuing our discussion of Article 1 with special guest,
这个。实际上只是一种以结果为导向的方法来看待联邦政府的运作方式。我的意思是，我认为未能将抽象结构帮助人们实现他们投票支持的实质性结果这一事实联系起来，是一个真正的失败。我们在上一次大选中了解到，这种民主的死讯或我们的民主规范正在受到侵蚀的想法，并不是一个那么具有激励性的想法。对。这太过了。这太像课堂了，没有足够的，你知道的，走出去用双脚投票。非常感谢。谢谢，罗曼。下个月加入我们。我们将继续讨论第一条，特邀嘉宾是
Senator Elizabeth Warren. The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Constitution is produced by Isabel Angel and Jacob Medina Gleason, edited by committee. Music by Swan Real and from Dune Tree Records, mixed by Martine Gonzalez. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Kathy, too. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kirk Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Christopher Rubet, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian, Leigh, Loshamadon, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of Visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
参议员伊丽莎白·沃伦。《99%隐形宪法解剖》由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔和雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森制作，委员会编辑。音乐由斯旺·里尔和杜恩树唱片公司提供，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。《99%隐形》执行制片人是凯茜·图。我们的资深编辑是德莱尼·霍尔。柯克·科尔斯特德担任数字总监。团队其余成员包括克里斯托弗·鲁贝特、杰森·德莱昂、埃mett菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、洛沙马顿、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are a part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media science as well as our own Discord server. We have fun discussions about constitutional law, about architecture, about movies, about music, all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most of these days. You can find a link to the Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. EOOOOOOOOOOO There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。在美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体科学以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到这个节目。我们针对宪法、建筑、电影、音乐等各种好东西进行有趣的讨论。这就是我这些天大部分时间闲逛的地方。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。呃噢噢噢噢噢噢噢噢噢本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。